You know, your eyes go through a lot. Every day with things like reading and dim light, too much screen time, that happens to me all the time. Bright sun in your eyes when you're driving. Even nighttime driving can cause eye strain. So, yeah, we're putting our eyes through a lot. So it's important to take care of them and monitor their health with regular eye exams. Check their healthy with an eye exam at spec savers from $99, which includes an OCT eye health scan that helps to detect eye. and health conditions at early stages.
你知道，你的眼睛承受了很多。每天阅读、处于昏暗光线中、屏幕使用时间过长，这种事经常发生在我身上。开车时刺眼的阳光直射眼睛。甚至夜间开车也会导致眼部疲劳。所以，是的，我们的眼睛承受了很大压力。因此，通过定期视力检查来照顾它们并监测它们的健康状况非常重要。在 Specsavers 进行视力检查，费用从 99 美元起，其中包括 OCT 眼部健康扫描，有助于及早发现眼部和健康问题。
To find a location near you and book an eye exam with an OCT scan from $99, visit specksavers.cavers.ca. I exams are provided by independent optometrists. Prices may vary by location. I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on the office together. And we're best friends.
要查找离您最近的分店并预约含 OCT 扫描的视力检查（99 美元起），请访问 specsavers.ca。视力检查由独立验光师提供。价格可能会因分店而异。我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金西。我们曾一起出演《办公室》。而且我们是最好的朋友。
And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week, we will break down an episode of the office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're the office ladies. Hi there. Hey there. How are you? I'm good. How are you? I'm sluggish. I think it's the heat. Well, it's very hot. It's very hot. I'm wearing one of those dresses that doesn't touch you anywhere. Yeah, it's so hot. It's too hot. I'm wearing flip flops. I never do that when we record. Oh, I wear them all the time. When we record? Yeah, look at my feet right now. Oh, yeah. There you go.
现在，我们专门为你制作了《办公室》终极重看播客。每周，我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室辣妈。大家好。嗨。你好吗？我很好。你呢？我觉得没精打采的。我想是天气太热了。嗯，天气非常热。非常热。我穿了一条那种无论哪个部位都不会贴到皮肤的裙子。对，太热了。太热了。我穿着人字拖。我录音时从来不穿这个。哦，我经常穿。录音的时候？对，现在看看我的脚。哦，对。就是这样。
Well, now that you know what we're wearing, Jenna, what are you wearing? I am wearing these, like, black, what would you call them? They're like the big leg pants. Well, these are like my find of the year. Uh-huh. A mom friend of mine, she's French. No. She has the cutest pants all the time.
既然你知道我们穿什么了，珍娜，你穿的是什么？我穿的是这种黑色的，你会怎么称呼它们？它们有点像大腿裤。好吧，这些就像是我今年的重大发现。嗯哼。我有个当妈妈的朋友，她是法国人。不是吧。她总是穿着最可爱的裤子。
Mm-hmm. Of course, she's French. She's got the chic. She's style. Yes. She told me about them, and they're very cool. They're very billowy. and then I have on a cool billowy blacktop to go with it.
嗯哼。当然，她是法国人。她很有风情。她很有品位。是的。她跟我提过这些裤子，它们非常酷。它们非常飘逸。然后我搭配了一件很酷、很飘逸的黑色上衣。
I'm billowy. You're billowy. I'm in a big flowy dress from Targette. Okay. Okay. Targette. Targe. It's also French.
我很飘逸。你很飘逸。我穿着一件来自塔吉特的宽大飘逸的连衣裙。好吧。好吧。塔吉特。Tar-ghee。这也是法语。
Now that we've got that out of the way. What are we talking about today? I loved this episode. I loved it so much. Oh, my gosh. I was so excited for these storylines. Is it any surprise that we loved this episode now that our characters finally have stories again. Could that be part of it? Maybe it's because our characters make it better.
既然我们已经把这些抛在脑后了。我们今天要聊什么？我很喜欢这一集。我太喜欢了。哦，天哪。我太期待这些故事线了。既然我们的角色终于又有了故事，我们喜欢这一集难道还奇怪吗？会不会是因为这个原因？也许是因为我们的角色让它变得更好了。
Well, we have it on very good authority from the writer's room. That's right. Yes, Steve Healy said. More episodes are better. Pam and Angela. It's official, and this episode proves it. We're talking about jury duty. We finally got there. It's season eight, episode 13, written by Erin Scher, who we love. Love. And directed by Eric Appel. Here is your summary. Jim is back from jury duty. Or is he? Turns out he was actually home helping Pam with the kids. Dwight figures this out and is determined to get Jim fired as a result. Also, Angela gives birth to a big, healthy preemie,
嗯，我们得到了编剧室非常可靠的权威消息。没错。是的，史蒂夫·希利说。更多剧集更好。帕姆和安吉拉。这是官方消息，这一集证明了这一点。我们在谈论陪审团职责。我们终于讲到这一集了。这是第八季第十三集，由我们深爱的埃琳·谢尔编剧。深爱。由埃里克·阿佩尔导演。以下是你的总结。吉姆从陪审团服务中回来了。还是说他根本没有？原来他其实是在家帮帕姆带孩子。德怀特发现了这一点，并决心因此开除吉姆。此外，安吉拉生下一个又大又健康的早产儿，
which causes some speculation about timelines and paternity. Oh, man. And Pam brings Cece and Philip into the office to visit. Fast fact number one, new director alert, Erica Pell. Eric has directed a ton of television. His background is an animation and sketch comedy, and he did improv at the Upright Citizens Brigade. Eric was fantastic. Fantastic. I'm going to get there. There's a scene between Dwight and Angela where he just let us go. I think I know which one. I think you do. Because I loved it. Eric has been nominated for and won several awards for his work. According to his IMDB page under the trivia section, Eric can try for.
这引发了关于时间线和生父身份的一些猜测。哦，天哪。帕姆带着西西和菲利普来到办公室探访。趣事一号，新导演警报，埃里克·阿佩尔。埃里克导演过大量电视剧。他的背景是动画和素描喜剧，他曾在アップライト・シチズンズ・ブリゲード（Upright Citizens Brigade）表演即兴喜剧。埃里克棒极了。棒极了。我马上讲到那儿。德怀特和安吉拉之间有一场戏，他直接让我们自由发挥。我想我知道是哪一场。我想你知道。因为我很喜欢。埃里克因其作品获得并被提名了多个奖项。根据他的 IMDB 页面上的冷知识部分，埃里克可以尝试用舌头……
his tongue. What? This is also sometimes referred to as a cloverleaf tongue. What is the trifold tongue? I had to Google it. I don't understand. Is that where you make it look like a flower kind of thing? Well, you tell me, I think it looks like a W. Like you're making a W with your tongue. While Googling what it was, I found out that Daniel Radcliffe can also do this. And here, Daniel Radcliffe did it once on a red carpet. There's Daniel Radcliffe's Trifold tongue. Wow. Yeah.
他的舌头。什么？这有时也被称为三叶草舌。什么是三叶舌？我不得不去谷歌搜索一下。我不明白。那是那种把它弄得看起来像一朵花一样的东西吗？嗯，你告诉我，我觉得它看起来像个 W。就像你用舌头做一个 W 一样。在谷歌搜索它是什么的时候，我发现丹尼尔·雷德克里夫也能做到这一点。你看，丹尼尔·雷德克里夫曾在红毯上做过一次。这是丹尼尔·雷德克里夫的三叶舌。哇。对。
That's impressive. I know. Okay. Well, according to an article on colgate.com, 14.7% of the population can trifle their tongue. Can anyone hear Sam, Cassie? Anyone trifold your tongue? Jenna clearly can't.
真令人印象深刻。我知道。好吧，根据 colgate.com 上的一篇文章，14.7% 的人口可以把舌头折成三叶。有人听到萨姆、卡西的声音吗？有人能把舌头折成三叶吗？珍娜显然不能。
She had to Google it. Hold on. Cassie's looking it up to see if she can. It looks like a W. It really looks like a W with your tongue. I can do the canoe thing with my tongue. I can do the canoe fold, and I can also fold my tongue in half like this. Oh, my God, that makes the grossest sound.
她不得不去谷歌搜索。等等。卡西正在查她能不能做到。它看起来像个 W。用舌头看真的像个 W。我可以用舌头做独木舟的形状。我可以做独木舟折叠，我也可以像这样把舌头对折。哦，天哪，这发出的声音太恶心了。
Oh, no. Well, it keeps popping up. It was really gross. So sorry, everyone. I had no idea we were going here this morning. Well, you never know. You know what? It's where my research took us.
哦，不。好吧，它一直在发出声音。真的很恶心。非常抱歉，大家。我今天早上根本不知道我们会聊到这个。好吧，你永远不会知道。你知道吗？这就是我的研究把我们带到的地方。
I love it. Would you like Fast fact number two? I can't wait. Fast fact number two is a fan question from Tracy W. in Norway. Jenna and Angela, I'm curious if you have ever had any interesting real-life personal experiences being summoned for jury duty. Tracy, I almost always get selected to be on a jury. I mean, every time I go in there, they're like, little blonde lady, get up here. I don't know why, but yes, I have many stories of jury duty.
我太喜欢了。你想听趣事二号吗？我都迫不及待了。趣事二号是来自挪威的特雷西·W 的粉丝提问。珍娜和安吉拉，我很想知道你们是否曾有过任何有趣的现实生活个人经历，被传唤去履行陪审团职责。特雷西，我几乎每次都被选中去陪审。我是说，每次我进去，他们都像是，那个金发小个子女士，上来。我不知道为什么，但是是的，我有很多关于陪审团职责的故事。
I think I've already shared one. Yeah, back when Toby had jury duty. Right. That was when I was a juror on a bait car case. But guess what I found in my digital clutter? And I didn't even know you had this question. What? I wrote you an email from one of the many times.
我想我已经分享过一个了。对，回到托比有陪审团职责的时候。对。那是我在一个诱捕汽车案件中担任陪审员的时候。但你猜我在我的数字杂乱中发现了什么？而且我甚至都不知道你有这个问题。什么？我给你写过一封邮件，是在我等待……
I was waiting to be, you know, picked for a jury, and I found it. Ready? Okay. I love this. This is from October 2018. All right. Okay. I wrote this.
被选中参加陪审团的众多日子之一写的，然后我找到了。准备好了吗？好的。我太喜欢这个了。这是 2018 年 10 月的。好吧。好的。我写了这封邮件。
And I sent you a picture, too. I took a selfie there. In the waiting room, guys, I wasn't in the courthouse, okay? Okay. That's right. You're not allowed to do that in the courthouse. But in that holding room, you can. Okay, here's what I emailed you.
我还给你发了一张照片。我在那里自拍了。在候诊室里，伙计们，我当时不在法庭里，好吗？好的。没错。你在法庭里是不被允许这么做的。但在那个候诊室里，你可以。好吧，这是我发给你的邮件。
Hey, lady, day two. I'm waiting to see if I get picked for a jury. I'm sitting in a big room with a bunch of people, and we all have those chairs from high school that have a mini desk attached to them. I feel like I'm in a study hall at a school for random adults. I brought townhouse crackers and some cheese. And the guy next to me looks up every time I bite into a cracker. I also brought my laptop and have Wi-Fi.
嘿，女士，第二天。我在等看自己会不会被选为陪审员。我坐在一个大房间里，里面有一群人，我们都坐着那种连着小桌子的中学教室里的椅子。我觉得自己就像是在一个随机成年人的学校里的自习室。我带了汤城苏打饼干和一些奶酪。我旁边的那个人每次我咬饼干时都会抬起头来。我还带了笔记本电脑，而且有 Wi-Fi。
So email away or leave me a message. I have headphones. You wrote back. You look amazing. Why do you have such pretty hair for jury duty? Oh, my God. Angela, you brought cheese to jury duty. And townhouse crackers.
所以尽管发邮件或者给我留言吧。我有耳机。你回信了。你看起来太棒了。为什么你履行陪审团职责时头发能这么漂亮？哦，天哪。安吉拉，你竟然带了奶酪去履行陪审团职责。还有汤城苏打饼干。
It's so you. And I took a selfie and you see me holding like a, a Ziploc of crackers. Oh, that's incredible. That is incredible. All right, I have a crazy story. Okay. I was on jury duty the week we were prepping this episode to record. I was on jury duty. That is crazy. But it was a mistake. What do you mean? So, how? Okay. So I was supposed to do jury duty. Yeah. And I broke my shoulder and I couldn't drive. I couldn't go. Yes. So I postponed it. Sure. But I forgot to when I postponed it. And suddenly it popped up on my calendar. I got a reminder on the Sunday night before. My husband was out of town the whole week. Lee was gone. He had to go to Chicago. And I was the only parent. And I thought, oh, my gosh, I can't. I'm the only one home. I can't do it. What if I could pick for a jury? So I can't do jury duties. So I go on the computer. They have a portal. You log in with your juror ID number.
这太符合你的风格了。我还拍了一张自拍照，你能看到我拿着一袋封口袋装着的饼干。哦，太不可思议了。这太不可思议了。好吧，我有一个疯狂的故事。好的。就在我们准备录制这一集的那个星期，我正在履行陪审团职责。我当时在履行陪审团职责。这太疯狂了。但这其实是个误会。什么意思？所以，怎么回事？好吧。所以我本来应该去履行陪审团职责的。对。然后我摔断了肩膀，没法开车。我没法去。是的。所以我延期了。当然。但我忘了自己是什么时候延期了。然后它突然出现在我的日历上。我在那之前的周日晚上收到了提醒。我丈夫那一整周都不在城里。李出去了。他得去芝加哥。我是唯一的家长。我想，哦，天哪，我不行。我是唯一在家的人。我做不到。如果我被选为陪审团怎么办？所以我没法履行陪审团职责。所以我上网了。他们有一个门户网站。你用你的陪审员 ID 号登录。
Yes. And so I go to the portal and it says you can't postpone anymore. You had to do that by the Friday before. Yeah. But it also said you don't have to report tomorrow Monday. Check in again Monday evening to see if you have to report Tuesday. So you just rolled the dice. You had to.
是的。所以我去了门户网站，上面说你不能再延期了。你必须在之前的星期五之前完成。对。但它也说你明天星期一不用去报到。星期一晚上再查看一次，看你星期二是否需要报到。所以你只是碰碰运气。你不得不这样做。
I did. I rolled the dice every night at 7 p.m. I would log into my jury portal and every night it said you don't have to report. and then on Thursday night it said you've completed your jury duty. Oh my gosh. I completed it by mistake. How lucky was I? Very lucky.
我确实这么做了。我每天晚上 7 点都碰碰运气。我会登录我的陪审团门户网站，每天晚上它都说你不需要报到。然后到了星期四晚上，它说你已经完成了陪审团职责。哦，天哪。我阴差阳错地完成了。我有多幸运？非常幸运。
I mean, considering everything, you were like single parenting. Yes. I will say, anyone that knows our mom detective hearts knows that we would actually be thrilled to get picked under different circumstances. Yeah, I've reported many times and I've never been selected. Oh, I always get selected and I get very excited. That tracks. Yeah. And I bring a notepad and a pen so people know I'm serious.
我是说，考虑到所有情况，你就像是在独自抚养孩子。是的。我必须说，任何了解我们具有妈妈侦探直觉的人都知道，在不同的情况下，我们实际上会很高兴被选中。是的，我报到过很多次，但从来没有被选中。哦，我总是被选中，而且我非常兴奋。这很符合逻辑。是的。我带了一个记事本和一支笔，好让别人知道我是认真的。
Maybe that's why you're getting picked. I don't know. Well, those are our jury duty stories. Moving us now to Fast Fact 3, I titled it, Pam is back. Yes, Pam is back. Everyone, I did this episode five weeks after having a C-section. I did that because actors do not get paid maternity leave. That is true.
也许这就是你被选中的原因。我不知道。好吧，这就是我们的陪审团职责故事。现在进入趣事三号，我给它起的名字是：帕姆回来了。是的，帕姆回来了。各位，我是在做完剖腹产五周后拍摄这一集的。我之所以这样做，是因为演员没有带薪产假。这是真的。
We go on unpaid disability, which means your employer can't fire you, but they do not have to pay you. Yep. So every time I missed an episode, I missed a paycheck. That's right. I wrote about it in our book. Yeah. We got a lot of mail about this, people who had read our book and were surprised to learn about this. Mm-hmm.
我们享受的是无薪病假，这意味着你的雇主不能解雇你，但他们没有义务付你工资。是的。所以每当我错过一集，我就错过了一张薪水支票。没错。我在我们的书里写过这件事。是的。我们收到了很多关于这方面的信件，那些读过我们书的人都很惊讶地知道了这一点。嗯哼。
We got a fan question from Kathleen M in North Carolina who said, In your book, the Office BFFs, Jenna shared about how hard it was for her to return and film this episode after having her baby and how supportive everyone was. I'd love to hear more about what it was like to film an episode of TV right after having your baby, and what was going through your head when filming these scenes. Well, Kavilleen, it was very, very hard. I could not walk without pain. I was uncomfortable.
我们收到了来自北卡罗来纳州的粉丝 Kathleen M 的提问，她说：“在你们的书《办公室密友》中，珍娜分享了她在生完孩子仅仅五周后回到片场拍摄这一集是多么困难，以及每个人都多么支持她。我很想听听更多关于生完孩子后立刻去拍电视剧是什么感觉，以及你在拍摄这些场景时脑子里在想什么。”嗯，凯琳，这真的非常非常难。我走路都会痛。我很不舒服。
I was still bleeding. As you bleed a lot after you have a baby, it doesn't matter if it's C-section or vaginal. Yeah, yeah. I was still working with a lactation consultant trying to get my son to nurse well. I was very worried about messing up his feeding schedule. At the same time, coming back to work meant that I got to see all of these people who just loved me so much. The cast and the crew, and I'd been very isolated at home. Parents know this when you have a new baby.
我还在流血。因为你生完孩子后会流很多血，不管你是剖腹产还是顺产。对，对。我还在和哺乳顾问合作，试图让我儿子好好吮吸。我很担心搞砸他的喂养时间表。与此同时，回到工作岗位意味着我能见到所有这些非常爱我的人。演员和剧组人员，而在家里我一直非常孤立。当你有了一个新宝宝，父母们都懂这种感受。
We get letters from people who tell us we're keeping them company at home in those early months. I remember loving having friends that had a big time difference who were already awake. You know, my friends on the East Coast because I, I would be up at like 4 a.m. Yeah. And I knew I could call and just kind of talk to them while I breastfed. Well, the part of getting to see people, I loved that. Yeah. That was good for my soul, because I'd been very like in a cocoon, you know? Yeah. And then when we started filming, my adrenaline really kicked in. It was almost dreamlike. I don't have any real memories that when I watched that scene, I feel like I dreamed it. I was like. I guess I was there. So we also got another
我们收到过人们的来信，他们告诉我们在那些早期的月份里，是我们在家里陪伴着他们。我记得我很庆幸能有一些有时差、已经醒着的朋友。你知道，我在东海岸的朋友们，因为我会在凌晨 4 点左右醒来。是的。我知道我可以打电话，在哺乳的时候和他们聊聊天。好吧，能见到人的这一部分，我很喜欢。是的。这对我的灵魂很有益，因为我一直像是在一个茧里，你知道吗？是的。然后当我们开始拍摄时，我的肾上腺素真的飙升了。这几乎就像做梦一样。当我看着那一幕时，我没有任何真实的记忆，我觉得自己好像是在做梦。我当时想。我想我当时在那儿。所以我们还收到了……
letter from Alexis K in California, who said, Jenna, after listening to your experience in your book about coming back to work just five weeks after having your baby, I'm floored. I also had a C-section, and I can't imagine going back to work that quickly. I am so in awe and just wanted to say that you looked amazing. You looked peaceful, glowing, and at ease, although I'm sure you were so overwhelmed with many emotions. You mentioned in the book that Angela and the rest of the cast and crew were really supportive, what else helped you in those first weeks of going back to work? Well, my husband Lee was amazing. We eventually had to hire a nanny, but we had not done that yet. It was five weeks. Yeah. We were like still figuring out how to swaddle. Yeah. So for this episode,
来自加利福尼亚州的 Alexis K 的来信，她说：“珍娜，听了你在书中关于生完孩子仅五周就重返工作岗位的经历，我惊呆了。我也经历过剖腹产，我无法想象那么快就回去工作。我太佩服你了，只想说你看上去太棒了。你看上去平静、焕发光彩且从容不迫，尽管我确信你内心一定百感交集。你在书中提到安吉拉以及其他演员和剧组人员都非常支持你，在重返工作岗位的最初几周里，还有什么对你有所帮助？”嗯，我丈夫李太棒了。我们最终不得不雇一个保姆，但当时我们还没那么做。那时才五周。是的。我们当时还在摸索怎么给婴儿裹襁褓。是的。所以对于这一集，
he came to work with me. He had our son in my trailer with him so that I could nurse him. Because like I said, I was still trying to get that down. So that was really helpful. And I would have to shout out our first stay D. Kelly Cantley because she was instrumental in making that happen. Here's what she told me. She got me aside and she said, Jenna, I am legally required to let you leave set to pump milk. I am not legally required to let you nurse your baby. So you just say, Kelly, I need to pump. And then you get to go to your trailer. And if you put that milk into a pump or right into your baby who's waiting for you, that's none of my business. You just say, I need to. You just say, I need to go to your trailer. And then you get to go to your who's waiting for you. That's none of my business. You just say, I need to pump. Got it. And I like
他跟着我来上班了。他把我们儿子放在我的化妆车里陪着他，这样我就可以喂他。因为就像我说的，我还在努力掌握这个。所以这真的很有帮助。我必须感谢我们的第一助理导演凯利·坎特利（Kelly Cantley），因为她在促成这件事上起到了关键作用。这是她对我说的话。她把我拉到一边对我说：“珍娜，法律规定我必须让你离开片场去挤奶。法律并没有规定我必须让你喂养你的宝宝。所以你只需要说，‘凯利，我需要挤奶。’然后你就可以回你的化妆车了。至于你把奶挤进吸奶器里，还是直接喂给你那个在等你的宝宝，这不管我的事。你只需要说：‘我需要。’你只需要说，‘我需要回化妆车。’然后你就可以去……那个在等你的宝宝……这不管我的事。你只需要说：‘我需要挤奶。’明白了。”我当时……
broke down crying. Yeah. Because I was like, got it. I got what she was saying to me, you know? Yeah. Yeah. And I would like to say, Alexis, thank you for saying I looked amazing. I think every postpartum mom out there knows what that was like for me. I was very, I felt very vulnerable. Yeah. When I got to work that day, Alicia, our costume designer, showed me some clothes. I put something on. She said, we're done. I'm not going to make you change over and over again. Right. The hair and makeup folks were amazing. Kim Ferry put my hair in a ponytail. She was like, this is easy. I believe this. We're done. You know what? I've never shared. What? So I went back to work. I was almost seven weeks. I did not plan this, but I had my baby a week before we went on summer hiatus. It was not planned. It just worked out like that. So I had a little extra time there.
放声大哭。是的。因为我想，我懂了。我懂她对我说的话了，你知道吗？是的。是的。我想要说，亚历克西斯，谢谢你夸我看起来棒极了。我想每一位产后妈妈都懂我当时的感受。我很……我感觉自己非常脆弱。是的。当我那天去上班时，我们的服装设计师艾丽西亚给我看了一些衣服。我穿上一件。她说：“好了，我们搞定。我不会让你一遍又一遍地换衣服的。”没错。发型和化妆师们太棒了。金·费里（Kim Ferry）把我的头发扎成了一个马尾辫。她当时说：“这很简单。我相信这个。我们搞定了。”你知道吗？我从来没有分享过一件事。什么？所以我回去工作了。我快七周了。我不是计划好的，但我的孩子是在我们放暑假前一周出生的。这不是计划好的。事情就那样发生了。所以我当时有一点点额外的时间。
But I went back and my first week back, we had a whole cast photo shoot. Oh, wow. Yes. Where we take all the publicity photos? Yes. Yes. And I often, you know, when we go to things, sometimes people have stuff for us to sign, people will bring that photo. And every time I sign it, I think I had just pumped.
但我回去了，我回去的第一周，我们有一个全剧组的合影。哦，哇。是的。就是我们拍所有宣传照的地方？是的。是的。而且我经常，你知道的，当我们去参加活动时，有时人们会带东西让我们签名，人们就会带那张照片。每次我签名的时候，我都在想，我当时刚刚挤过奶。
Like, I had just, like, that was, you know. And now this photo is going to live forever. Forever. And I was like, anyway, it's just kind of a crazy thing to do when you go back to work after giving birth. So listen, we got a lot of mail on this subject and a lot of people just asking me, how did you do this? I did it because the women on the set showed up for me. They made it possible for me to come and get my paychecks. And that's what women do for one another all the time.
就像我刚刚……那就是，你知道的。现在这张照片将永远流传下去。永远。我当时想，无论如何，生完孩子后重返工作岗位，这真是一件疯狂的事情。所以听着，我们收到了很多关于这个主题的信件，很多人都在问我，你是怎么做到的？我做到这一点是因为片场的女演员们为我挺身而出。她们让我有可能来上班并拿到薪水。这就是女性一直在为彼此做的事情。
Yep. We fill in the gaps. We sure do. You know, they could have made a hiatus here. We'd done it in the past. The suits. The suits could have made it happen. The suits could have made a hiatus for my maternity leave. We'd made hiatuses for people to do movies before.
是的。我们填补空白。我们当然会。你知道，他们本可以在这里安排一个假期。我们以前做过。高层。高层本可以做到这一点的。高层本可以为我的产假安排一个假期的。我们以前为了别人拍电影而安排过假期。
They had. But they didn't. And so, you know, I went on unpaid disability, but the women in our casting crew, they filled in that gap. And that's why I was able to come back to work and get paid. And I will be forever grateful. Yeah. We do that all the time for one another. I know every woman out there has a story.
他们确实做过。但他们没有。所以，你知道的，我休了无薪病假，但是我们剧组的女演员们，她们填补了这个空白。这就是为什么我能够重返工作岗位并获得报酬。我将永远心存感激。是的。我们一直在为彼此这样做。我知道每一位女性都有一个……
about a woman that stood in for her. Yeah. Lifted her up, supported her. Yeah. Got her through. Yep. So thank you to Kelly and the hair and makeup women and Alicia in wardrobe and just you, Angela. You guys were great.
关于一个曾经支持过她的女性的故事。是的。拉她一把，支持她。是的。陪她度过难关。是的。所以谢谢凯利、发型和化妆师们、服装部的艾丽西亚，还有你，安吉拉。你们太棒了。
And listen, the other casting crew were amazing as well. But did they guard your door when you went in to pump? No, it was only you lady. That's right. All right. Well, let's take a quick break because when we come back, somebody's got to cut loose. Foot loose. I loved this.
听着，其他的演员和剧组人员也同样非常棒。但是当你进去挤奶时，他们会帮你守门吗？不，只有你，女士。没错。好吧，让我们快速休息一下，因为当我们回来时，有人得放松一下了。身不由己（Footloose）。我太喜欢这个了。
And I have a backstory about why the scene happened. Oh my gosh. I can't wait. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. You know, just because it's a new year, that does not mean you have to be a new you. But maybe you want to be a less burdened you, a clearer you. Yeah. Not a totally new you, but maybe like you just want to hone in.
而且关于这场戏为什么会发生，我还有一个幕后故事。哦，天哪。我都等不及了。本节目由 BetterHelp 赞助。你知道，仅仅因为迎来了新的一年，并不意味着你必须变成一个全新的自己。但也许你想成为一个负担更轻、思虑更清晰的自己。是的。不是一个完全崭新的自己，但也许就像你想磨练一下自己。
You want to refine. Yeah. I like that. Refine. Well, therapy can help more easily identify what is weighing you down, what might be holding you back. You can better understand your relationships, your motivations, your emotions. I'm trying to let go of just sort of stressing about the small things.
你想精进自己。是的。我喜欢这个词。精进。那么，心理咨询可以帮助你更轻松地识别是什么让你感到沉重，是什么在阻碍你。你可以更好地理解自己的人际关系、动机和情感。我正在努力不再为一些小事感到压力。
Mm-hmm. Because those really just add up. Mm-hmm. And they're going to be just fine. Well, and you might need help identifying what are small things, what are big things. Mm-hmm. Better help therapists can help. With over 30,000 therapists, BetterHelp is the world's largest online therapy platform, having served over 5 million people globally.
嗯哼。因为那些真的只是在积少成多。嗯哼。而且一切都会好起来的。嗯，你可能需要帮助来识别什么是小事，什么是大事。嗯哼。BetterHelp 的心理咨询师可以提供帮助。BetterHelp 拥有超过 3 万名心理咨询师，是全球最大的在线心理咨询平台，已为全球超过 5 百万人提供过服务。
BetterHelp makes it easy to get matched online with a qualified therapist. Sign up and get 10% off at BetterHelp.com slash office ladies. That's better, h-elp.com slash office ladies. We are back, and this episode starts with Andy bursting into the warehouse door at the top of the stairs. and he tells Val he needs the space. Yeah. Clear out. That's right.
BetterHelp 让你可以轻松在网上匹配到合格的心理咨询师。注册并在 BetterHelp.com/officeladies 上即可享受 90% 折扣（译者注：原文为 10% off，即九折）。网址是 better, h-elp.com/officeladies。我们回来了，这一集一开始，安迪就冲进楼梯顶部的仓库大门。他告诉瓦尔他需要这个空间。是的。清空。没错。
And Val is like, okay, but just promise to clean up. And he's like, I will. She's like, you have to promise to clean up. So clearly, Andy's about to do something he's done before, and that makes quite a big mess. Yeah. Well, I want you guys to know there was a deleted scene that would have started this episode totally differently and given the backstory why Andy comes barreling through that warehouse door. Okay. It was a montage of Andy's morning.
瓦尔说，好吧，但答应要打扫干净。他说，我会的。她说，你必须答应打扫干净。所以很明显，安迪又要做出他以前做过的事情，那会弄出一团大乱子。是的。好吧，我想让你们知道，有一个被删减的场景，原本会以完全不同的方式开启这一集，并交代安迪为什么会气势汹汹地冲过那个仓库大门的背景故事。好的。那是安迪早晨的一段蒙太奇。
He pulls into the parking lot and he spills coffee on his pants leg as he gets out of his car. Okay. He's like, dang it. Then he goes into the kitchen in the office and he gets a cup of coffee. And he grabs some milk out of the fridge to add to his coffee. And as he pours it, big clumps come out of the milk carton. Right? It's gone bad.
他把车开进停车场，下车时把咖啡洒在了裤腿上。好吧。他想，该死。然后他走进办公室的厨房，倒了一杯咖啡。他从冰箱里拿了一些牛奶加到咖啡里。当他倒牛奶时，牛奶盒里倒出了一大块一大块的东西。对吧？它变质了。
Can I say something? Yeah. This is why you put your milk into the coffee cup before the coffee. Oh. Because then you can see the milk. And also you don't need a spoon. It mixes while you put the coffee in. I do this every morning.
我能说句话吗？可以。这就是为什么你要先把牛奶倒进咖啡杯里，然后再倒咖啡。哦。因为那样你就能看到牛奶了。而且你还不需要勺子。在你倒咖啡的同时它就混匀了。我每天早上都这样做。
This is a coffee drinker's hack I didn't know about. Yeah, put the milk in first. You'll get the level. You'll know. Okay. All right, go ahead. Well, Andy didn't do that. No, now he's ruined his coffee.
这是一个我以前不知道的咖啡饮用小技巧。对，先把牛奶倒进去。你会掌握好分量的。你会知道的。好吧。好吧，你接着说。嗯，安迪没有那样做。不，现在他的咖啡毁了。
Now he's super bummed because his first cup of coffee he spilled on his pants leg. The second cup is now full of this chunky milk. Then he goes to get another cup of coffee. He goes over to the coffee pot. It's out. He's like, ugh. So then he goes into the freezer to grab the coffee. coffee grinds to make new coffee, and he takes the bag out of the freezer and it's empty.
现在他超级沮丧，因为他第一杯咖啡洒在了裤腿上。第二杯现在全是一块块的凝固牛奶。然后他去弄另一杯咖啡。他走到咖啡壶前。咖啡没了。他想，呃。所以然后他走进冰箱去拿咖啡。咖啡渣来煮新咖啡，他把袋子从冰箱里拿出来，结果是空的。
Oh, I thought it spilled. Empty. Either or bad. Who puts things back in the freezer empty? I'll tell you who, my teenagers. Mm-hmm. You want a popsicle? Don't even bother going for that box.
哦，我还以为是洒了。空的。要么就是坏了。谁会把空的东西放回冰箱里？我来告诉你谁会，我的青少年们。嗯哼。你想吃冰棒吗？甚至都不要费心去拿那个盒子了。
It's empty. Then he leaves the kitchen in a huff with no coffee. He's walking back towards his office, and Aaron stops him and says, hey, you are getting a huge facts from corporate. Like 200 pages of forms you're going to need to fill out. That's it. He can't take it anymore. He's like, and he goes to the warehouse.
它是空的。然后他气冲冲地离开厨房，没有喝到咖啡。他正走回自己的办公室，艾琳拦住他说，嘿，公司发来了一个巨大的传真。就像有 200 页的表格需要你填写。就是这样。他再也受不了了。他说，然后他去了仓库。
After a morning like that, I would need to blow off steam with a mega dance. You might need to mega dance. As well. Yeah, you might need to dance on some of those little bubble poppet thingies. Well, Andy is going to put footloose on the boom box, and he is going to do an epic dance montage. Did you know that the original song in the script was not footloose? What was it? It was Last Resort by Papa Roach.
经历了一个这样的早晨之后，我需要通过一场疯狂的舞蹈来发泄压力。你可能也需要疯狂舞蹈。一样。是的，你可能需要在那些小的气泡泡泡纸上跳舞。好吧，安迪要在音箱上播放《Footloose》，他要跳一段史诗般的舞蹈蒙太奇。你知道剧本里原本的歌不是《Footloose》吗？那是哪首？是 Papa Roach 的《Last Resort》。
Oh, I don't know. Huh. We ended up using Footloose. It cost $45,000. Woo. I know. Wow. That's a dance.
哦，我不知道。哈。我们最后用了《Footloose》。花了两万美元。哇。我知道。哇。那可真是一支舞。
Well, you know, Andy dancing to Footloose made me think of that game six degrees of Kevin Bacon. Oh, yeah. Okay, you guys know this, right? The theory is that anyone can be linked through their film or TV roles back to Kevin Bacon within six steps. Mm-hmm. Okay. Lady, guess what? What?
好吧，你知道的，安迪伴随着《Footloose》跳舞让我想起了那个游戏：凯文·培根的六度分隔。哦，对。好吧，你们都知道这个，对吧？这个理论是，任何人都可以通过他们的电影或电视角色在六步之内与凯文·培根联系起来。嗯哼。好吧。女士，你猜怎么着？什么？
You and I are two degrees from Kevin Bacon. We are? Yes. Because Steve Corell and Kevin Bacon were both in crazy stupid love. Wow. Two degrees. And then us. Wouldn't that be one degree?
你和我距离凯文·培根只有两度。真的吗？是的。因为史蒂夫·卡瑞尔和凯文·培根都出演过《疯狂愚蠢的爱》。哇。两度。然后是我们。难道那不应该是一度吗？
One degree. Wait, you don't count Kevin Bacon, I just realized. Yeah. He's what we're a degree from. We're one degree. We basically know him. We basically know him. I've never met him.
一度。等等，我不算凯文·培根，我刚刚意识到。对。他是我们相隔度数的目标。我们是一度。我们基本上认识他。我们基本上认识他。我从来没见过他。
I have not met him. I don't think I know. I would remember. meeting Kevin Bacon. Kevin Bacon, we're one degree. I feel like we could invite him over because we're one degree. Like to our house? I don't know. Like to barbecue? Yeah. I feel like we could. Can we just say, hey, you worked with someone we know. Oh my gosh. We got a fan question about this cold open from Haley B in Oklahoma who said, did Ed get to just have fun and do his own thing, or was this all scripted?
我没见过他。我想我不认识。我会记得见过凯文·培根的。凯文·培根，我们相隔一度。我觉得我们可以邀请他过来，因为我们只相隔一度。就像邀请到我们家里？我不知道。就像烧烤？对。我觉得我们可以。我们难道不能说，嘿，你和我们认识的人合作过吗？哦，天哪。我们收到了一个来自俄克拉荷马州的粉丝 Haley B 关于这个片头开场的提问，她说：“艾德是得以尽情发挥做他自己，还是这一切都是按剧本演的？”
Well, Steve Burgess said he does not have any choreographer on the schedule for this week. So he thinks that means the dancing was all Ed's creation. I did look in the script, and there are very detailed stage directions for the dancing. About the bubble wrap? Yes, it included the tap dancing on large bubble wrap. Also, Andy skateboards on the push cart. And Andy takes a large bag of shredded paper and makes it snow while laughing giddly. that was what was in the script, along with other things.
嗯，史蒂夫·伯吉斯说本周的日程表上没有任何编舞。所以他认为这意味着舞蹈完全是艾德自己创作的。我确实看了一下剧本，里面有关于舞蹈非常详细的舞台指导。关于气泡膜的？是的，包括在大型气泡膜上跳踢踏舞。还有，安迪在手推车上玩滑板。安迪还拿了一大包碎纸，一边开心地笑，一边制造了一场雪。剧本里就是这样写的，还有其他一些东西。
There was a big list. So, yeah, combo scripted and having fun, I think. When I watched it, I really wish that I could run on that bubble wrap. That looked like fun to me. I really wanted to dance on the paper confetti. I was super jealous when I watched this. I was like, I really wish this had been my cold open. That's a fun day.
有一个很大的清单。所以，是的，我觉得这是剧本与即兴随性玩乐的结合。当我看着这一幕时，我真的很希望我也能在那个气泡膜上跑。在我看来那太有趣了。我真的很想在纸屑里跳舞。我看的时候超级嫉妒。我当时想，我真的希望这是我的开场白。那真是愉快的一天。
That seemed amazing. Well, this episode opens with Jim returning back to the office from jury duty. Everybody's very happy to see him. Yeah. They kind of want to know, like, how'd it go? What was your case? He says it was a hit and run. They found him not guilty.
那看起来太棒了。好吧，这一集的开场是吉姆结束陪审团职责回到办公室。每个人都非常高兴见到他。是的。他们有点想知道，比如，进展怎么样？你的案子是什么？他说是一起交通肇事逃逸。他们判被告无罪。
I was so intrigued by this. Why would Jim pick hit and run? I don't know, because that feels like something that might have lasted a week. Yeah. Feels like a five-day trial. Yeah. I mean, I guess you either did it or you didn't. Yeah, but you got to present all the evidence.
我对这个太感兴趣了。为什么吉姆会选交通肇事逃逸？我不知道，因为这感觉像是可能会持续一周的事情。是的。感觉像是一个五天的审判。是的。我是说，我猜你要么做了要么没做。是的，但你得呈上所有的证据。
Yeah. Well, I was curious about is this maybe something that. the writers knew about, like hit and run cases, and this is what I found. In Pennsylvania, particularly in Philadelphia, hit and run accidents happen at an alarming rate. Really? Yes. According to the AAA Foundation for Traffic Safety, hit and run accidents are a problem throughout the United States. Approximately 4.6 out of every 10,000 motorists have at least one prior hit and run violation, and more than one hit and run crash occurs every 60 seconds. I would Was it a hit and run?
嗯，我好奇的是，这会不会是编剧们知道的事情，比如交通肇事逃逸案件，而这就是我所发现的。在宾夕法尼亚州，特别是费城，交通肇事逃逸事故以令人惊恐的高频率发生。真的吗？是的。根据美国汽车协会交通安全基金会的数据，交通肇事逃逸事故是全美国普遍存在的问题。大约每 10,000 名司机中就有 4.6 人至少有过一次以前的交通肇事逃逸违章记录，并且每 60 秒钟就会发生多起交通肇事逃逸车祸。我会……那是一起交通肇事逃逸吗？
There you go. You're part of the statistic. Somebody ran. I was in like a line of cars and someone hit me and then I hit the person in front of me because, you know, they propelled me into them. And we got out of our cars for a second. And then we signaled that we were all going to turn the corner to get off the main road. So me and the person in front of me, we turned the corner to get off the main road.
你看。你也是统计数据的一部分。有人撞了我。我当时在一排车里，有人撞了我，然后我撞了前面的那个人，因为，你知道的，他们把我撞得向前冲去。我们从车里出来了一秒钟。然后我们打手势示意大家都要拐弯离开主路。所以我和前面的那个人，我们拐弯离开了主路。
And then the hitter just took off. Wow. Just drove away. Yeah. Yeah. It's very common. And so maybe that's why the writers were like, oh, this is an easy fit. Yeah. Common.
然后那个肇事者就直接开走了。哇。直接开走了。是的。非常常见。所以也许这就是为什么编剧们觉得，哦，这很契合。是的。常见。
What? It's common. You just took a buzz. And then you went, common. Like, it's common. Like a robot. I was confirming. You're confirming. Did you know that you can get up to a year in prison or fine up to $2,500, depending on the damage cause to the property in a hit and run? I do now. There you go. It gets worse if the hit and run was worse, you know, the penalties.
什么？这很常见。你刚才只是发出嗡嗡声。然后你说，常见。就像个机器人。我在确认。你在确认。你知道在交通肇事逃逸中，根据对财产造成的损害，你可能会面临长达一年的监禁或高达 2,500 美元的罚款吗？我现在知道了。你看。如果肇事逃逸更严重，惩罚也会更重，你知道的。
Yes, the severity increases. That's right. With the severity. Severeity. Common. Common. Oh, Lord. We might need to take a coffee break for ourselves.
是的，严重程度会增加。没错。随着严重程度。严重程度。常见。常见。哦，天哪。我们可能需要给自己暂停喝杯咖啡了。
Well, Jim has a talking head where he says that he was called into jury duty, but they released him around noon. He didn't see any point in going back to work for just a half day. So he, you know, stayed home that day, helped Pam. Then he took the next day off to help Pam. And then three other days happened. Yeah. I loved that. I did that talk again.
好吧，吉姆有一个访谈镜头，他说他被传唤去履行陪审团职责，但他们在大约中午时分就放他走了。他觉得只上半天班再回去工作没有任何意义。所以他，你知道的，那天呆在家里，帮帕姆。然后他第二天请假帮帕姆。然后又过去了其他三天。是的。我很喜欢那个。我又做了一次访谈。
I also thought John did such a great job, his look at the end. Yeah. So, Ann, you looked up the statistics of hit and runs. I looked up the statistics for how likely it is that you'll get picked for a jury. How likely? Because I seem to get picked every time. I know. So according to the next.
我也觉得约翰做得太棒了，他最后的那个眼神。是的。所以，安，你查了交通肇事逃逸的统计数据。我查了你被选中参加陪审团的概率统计数据。概率有多大？因为我好像每次都被选中。我知道。所以根据下一个……
National Center for State Courts, it estimates that in any given year, 32 million people get summoned for jury duty, but only 8 million of them actually report. I report. You report. Now, it said, how do they not report? Well, they said there's like millions of jury summons that get returned, because the person isn't at that address anymore. There's a bunch of people that, you know, get out for certain reasons. So of the, of the- 32 million that they send out, 8 million report for jury duty, and of that 8 million, 1.5 people get selected to serve. I did the math. That means you have a roughly 19% chance of getting selected for a jury every time you report. If 1.5 of 8 million people. How do I continue to fall into the 19
国家州立法院中心估计，在任何特定年份，有 3200 万人被传唤履行陪审团职责，但实际上只有 800 万人去报到。我去报到了。你去报到了。现在，它说，他们怎么会不报到呢？嗯，它说有数百万份陪审团传票被退回，因为收件人已经不在那个地址了。有一群人，你知道的，因为某些原因被豁免了。所以在……在……发出的 3200 万人中，有 800 万人去履行陪审团职责，在这 800 万人中，有 150 万人被选中服务。我算了一下。这意味着你每次报到时，被选中加入陪审团的几率大约是 19%。如果 800 万人中有 150 万人的话。我怎么总是落入那 19% 呢？
I don't know. But I mean, that's pretty high. One in five, basically, chance of getting on a jury if you report. Yeah. So, yeah. We're handing out a lot of stats today. I know. We're stat-heavy. Do I have any more stats coming up? Papers. Papers. Let's see. Papers. I don't have any more stats. I don't have any more stats. I have lots of scripty stuff. Okay. Okay. No more stats. But go on. But the other thing that's going to happen in this scene is that Aaron is going to get like an email ding and she's like, oh, Angela had her baby. Yes. Everyone's so excited. Yeah, everyone's so excited. In the shooting draft, the scene was longer. And Oscar also gets the email, like a bunch of people, the email's popping up around the office. Okay.
我不知道。但我的意思是，那相当高。基本上每报到五个人，就有一个人有机会进陪审团。所以，是的。我们今天发出了很多统计数据。我知道。我们满是统计数据。我还有更多统计数据要公布吗？文件。文件。让我们看看。文件。我没有更多统计数据了。我没有更多统计数据了。我有很多剧本相关的内容。好的。好的。没有统计数据了。但继续吧。但这一集中还将发生的事情是，艾琳会收到一封电子邮件提示音，然后她说，哦，安吉拉生孩子了。是的。每个人都非常兴奋。是的，每个人都非常兴奋。在拍摄初稿中，这一段更长。而且奥斯卡也收到了这封邮件，就像办公室里很多人一样，邮件在办公室各处弹出来。好的。
And Oscar reads what the email said out loud. Oh. Yeah. Here's what he says to the group. It says that at 6.14 a.m., Angela Martin Lipton gave. birth to Philip Halstead-Libton, a five-pound, three-ounce baby boy. Mother and baby are healthy and happy. Hmm.
奥斯卡大声读出了邮件的内容。哦。是的。他是这样对大家说的。上面说，在早上 6 点 14 分，安吉拉·马丁·利普顿生下了……菲利普·霍尔斯特德-利普顿，一个重五磅三盎司的男婴。母子健康幸福。嗯。
Five pounds, three ounces. I feel like they should have left this in because that really sets up the scene later. Right. The pre-mey. Mm-hmm. Well, the accounting department's going to go see Angela. I mean, they're kind of like a little family. They are.
五磅三盎司。我觉得他们应该把这个保留下来，因为这为后来的情节做好了铺垫。对吧。早产儿。嗯哼。好吧，会计部要去看望安吉拉。我是说，他们有点像是一个小家庭。他们确实是。
Oscar's the dad. Kevin is Oscar's dad. And Angela is Kevin's mom. Mm-hmm. That's how Kevin breaks it down. Yeah. Gabe says he wants to go to. Apparently, he loves maternity wards. Yes, he says they're the perfect blend of love and horror.
奥斯卡是爸爸。凯文是奥斯卡的爸爸。安吉拉是凯文的妈妈。嗯哼。这就是凯文的分析方式。是的。盖比说他想去。显然他很喜欢产科病房。是的，他说那是爱与恐怖的完美结合。
Great. We did have a fan catch from Afrin R. in San Antonio who said, We know Gabe has weird fears, like his fear of cockroaches and getting squeamish around babies. But I guess he got over his fear of babies because here he says he loves going to maternity awards. Is this a continuity error, or did he get over this fear? Well, Afrin, I don't think he got over his fear. I think he's doing that thing where he's like walking into the spooky fun house. He's going to be creeped out when he sees the babies, but there's something about him that's drawn to it. That's what I got. Well, I think he's drawn to the process of the babies coming into the world. Labor. I think he's drawn to labor. Really? Yeah, that's my theory.
太棒了。我们确实收到了来自圣安东尼奥的 Afrin R. 的粉丝捉虫反馈，她说：“我们知道盖比有奇怪的恐惧症，比如他害怕蟑螂，对婴儿感到拘谨恶心。但我猜他克服了对婴儿的恐惧，因为在这里他说他喜欢去产科病房。这是一个连贯性错误，还是他克服了这种恐惧？”嗯，阿弗林，我不认为他克服了恐惧。我觉得他正在做那种类似于走进恐怖游乐屋的事情。当他看到婴儿时，他会感到毛骨悚然，但他身上有某种东西被它吸引。这就是我的理解。好吧，我认为他被婴儿来到这个世界的过程所吸引。分娩。我认为他被分娩吸引。真的吗？是的，这是我的理论。
It's odd anyway, you look at it. It sure is. Gabe is an odd bird. Well, a bunch of people start having excuses why they're not going to go, right? Jim says, oh, I've missed too much work. And Phyllis has this thing where she kind of trails off. She's like, I would, but, um, uh, right? She just trails off. Well, there was a line that was scripted for Phyllis, and I really wish it had made it in.
不管你怎么看，这都很奇怪。确实如此。盖比是个怪人。好吧，许多人开始找借口为什么他们不去，对吧？吉姆说，哦，我缺席的工作太多了。菲莉丝有这样一种情况，她的话说到一半就渐渐听不见了。她说，我愿意，但是，嗯，呃，对吧？她的话就那么渐渐听不到了。好吧，剧本里原本为菲莉丝写了一句台词，我真的很希望它能被剪进去。
I want to read it to you. Because to me, it just shows how well Phyllis knows Angela. Phyllis would have said, I don't know. Angela is a private person who doesn't do well. with kindness. Oh, that's such a good line. Isn't that perfect? That's so well written. Next up, we're in the break room, and Andy is asking Jim for more deets on his case. Everybody wants to hear more deets. Everyone's so excited. New information. New thing to talk about. Everyone says, listen, you kind of owe us. Like, we covered you all week. Yeah. People start
我想读给你们听。因为对我来说，它恰恰展现了菲莉丝有多了解安吉拉。菲莉丝本会说：“我不知道。安吉拉是一个私密的人，她不擅长接受别人的善意。”哦，这真是一句好台词。是不是很完美？写得太好了。接下来，我们在休息室里，安迪正在向吉姆打听他的案子的更多详情。每个人都想听更多详情。每个人都超级兴奋。有新信息了。有新话题可以聊了。每个人都说，听着，你多少欠我们点人情。比如，我们替你顶了一周的班。是的。人们开始
explaining things that happened. Phyllis got her car smashed visiting one of Jim's clients. Yeah, the least he can do is tell them the story of the case. Yeah. So Jim starts laying it out. He's using napkins and salt and pepper shakers. Then Toby says, oh, you know what my favorite part of jury duty was? I loved the empanadas from Ernesto. And Jim's like, yeah, I love that restaurant too.
解释发生的事情。菲莉丝去拜访吉姆的一个客户时，车被撞了。是的，他能做的最少的事就是把案子的故事讲给他们听。是的。于是吉姆开始摆明情况。他用餐巾纸和盐瓶胡椒瓶做道具。然后托比说，哦，你知道我最喜欢陪审团职责的哪一部分吗？我喜欢埃内斯特的恩番肉饼（empanadas）。吉姆说，是啊，我也很喜欢那家餐厅。
And Toby goes, don't you mean food truck? Oh, Dwight. Dwight, this is it. Dwight's ears go up to prove that Jim is lying. Dwight would make a very good mom detective. This whole episode is just Dwight being a mom detective, honestly. Yeah. Right?
然后托比说，难道你不是指餐馆的餐车吗？哦，德怀特。德怀特，就是这个。德怀特的耳朵竖起来了，试图证明吉姆在撒谎。德怀特会是一个非常优秀的妈妈侦探。说实话，这一整集就是德怀特在扮演妈妈侦探。是的。对吧？
Mm-hmm. And he doesn't really solve the crime that no one cared about. It's perfect. It's perfect. He did it. Well, I think Oscar is so brilliant in this episode. I actually just saw him. We had lunch.
嗯哼。而且他也没有真正破掉那个没人关心的案子。太完美了。太完美了。他做到了。嗯，我觉得奥斯卡在这集里表现得太精彩了。我其实刚见过他。我们一起吃过午饭。
And I was like, Oscar, when you gather everyone around before you walk into the hospital room and you're like, listen, I don't know if you've ever seen a preemie baby. It can be very shocking. Do not comment on it. I loved him in the scene. He's so good. And then they go in and see the biggest baby ever. I'll have you know that this hospital was not a real hospital. Angela, as you know, you were there.
然后我说，奥斯卡，当你在走进病房前把大家都召集起来，然后说，听着，我不知道你们有没有见过早产儿。可能会非常震撼。千万不要对它评头论足。我太喜欢他在那个场景里的表现了。他演得太棒了。然后他们走进去，看到了有史以来最大的婴儿。我得告诉你们，这家医院并不是一家真正的医院。安吉拉，如你所知，你当时也在场。
This was a set that we built over on our warehouse stages. Yep. That's my location report on the hospital, everybody. Yeah, it was great because we could walk back to our trailers. I loved it. Well, right away, Angela doesn't look happy to see any of her coworkers. I think Phyllis was right. Kevin immediately remarks on how fat the baby is.
这是一个我们在仓库摄影棚搭建的布景。没错。各位，这就是我对医院的实地报道。对，这太棒了，因为我们可以步行回我们的保姆车。我太喜欢了。嗯，一转眼，安吉拉看起来一点也不高兴见到她的任何同事。我觉得菲利斯是对的。凯文立刻评论说这个婴儿有多胖。
And Oscar's like, what are you doing? And he's like, what? You said, don't talk about it if it's small. You didn't say anything about it being giant. A big, giant fat baby. The senator calls Philip substantial, and Aaron says he's more than that. He's a monster. I'm sorry.
然后奥斯卡说，你在干什么？他说，什么？你说过，如果它小，就不要讨论。你可没说它是个庞然大物。一个又大又胖的巨婴。参议员叫菲利普“体型魁梧”，艾琳说他不止于此。他是个怪物。我很抱歉。
This baby is adorable. So cute. In fact, I know who played little Philip Halstead Lipton. He was played by Twins Allie and. Suzanne Hartman. So you're actually holding a little baby girls right there. Yeah. They were very sweet babies. They were so good. Well, just in case there was also a backup baby, Haley Escalante. You know, that's how they do it. They cast the twins, the twin babies, but there's always a backup baby. Yeah. Remember that episode when Pam brings her baby to Gabe's apartment. You know,
这个婴儿太可爱了。太可爱了。事实上，我知道是谁扮演了小菲利普·哈尔斯特德·利普顿。他是由双胞胎阿莉和苏珊·哈特曼扮演的。所以你当时手里其实抱着两个小女婴。对。她们是非常甜美的婴儿。她们太乖了。嗯，以防万一，还有一个替补婴儿，海莉·埃斯卡兰特。你知道，他们就是这样做的。他们挑选双胞胎婴儿，但总是会有一个替补婴儿。对。还记得帕姆把她的婴儿带到盖比公寓的那集吗？你知道，
and Dwight has to like soothe the baby and everybody was like, why is this baby look completely different? We had use a backup baby. Back up. Yeah, because the other babies were like very awake. They wouldn't sleep. We needed a baby, a sleeper. These babies were just the cutest. And I remember the mom was just standing right off camera there. And I remember talking to her and just how sweet she was and she was a fan of the show. And it was just, you know, it gave me baby fever. By this time, I had a toddler. I was like, nope, no. Stay focused, Ange. Well, you were very very. real in these scenes. Like, this is something I noticed. You're always adjusting your bra. My nursing bra. Yeah. Like, all of your movements, all of the ways you regarded the baby, it was so clear that you were a mom. I mean, if you go back and you look at when Pam had her
而且德怀特还得安抚婴儿，每个人都觉得，为什么这个婴儿看起来完全不一样？我们得用一个替补婴儿。替补。对，因为其他的婴儿都非常清醒。他们不睡觉。我们需要一个婴儿，一个爱睡觉的。这些婴儿简直太可爱了。我还记得妈妈就站在镜头外不远的地方。我记得和她聊天，她人真的太好了，而且她是这部剧的粉丝。这简直是，你知道的，让我萌生了想要孩子的冲动。那时候，我已经有一个幼儿了。我就想，不，不行。保持专注，安吉。嗯，你在这些场景里显得非常非常真实。就像，这是我注意到的一个细节。你总是在调整你的胸罩。我的哺乳胸罩。对。就像，你的所有动作，你看着婴儿的各种方式，很明显你是个妈妈。我的意思是，如果你回过头去看帕姆
first baby in the hospital, I watched those scenes and I'm like, I've clearly never had a baby before. But you, it was so real. It took me back to being in your hospital room. Yeah. When you had had Isabel. I was like, there she is. It was just like that. Except I did not have a fully blown out hairdo that had been flat ironed and makeup. If you did a side by side of what I look like in the hospital room and what Angela Martin looked like, that did crack me up because I remember you saying they put such thought into how Pam would look after having a baby in her hair sort of in this tousled kind of ponytail. And I look fully made up.
第一个婴儿在医院的场景，我看着那些场景心想，我显然从来没生过婴儿。但你，太真实了。把我带回了你在医院病房里的情景。对。当你生下伊莎贝尔的时候。我就想，她就在那里。就像那样。除了我没有一个精心吹风定型并熨平了的完全吹整好的发型和妆容。如果你把我在医院病房里的样子和安吉拉·马丁的样子做个对比，这确实让我觉得很好笑，因为我记得你说过，他们对帕姆生完婴儿后会是什么样子花了很多心思，她的头发梳成了一种这种凌乱的马尾辫。而我看起来是完全化了妆的。
But that tracks for me for Angela Martin. I don't know. I believe she brought her little makeup. bag and a flat iron to the hospital. Yes, I do too. I think she was like to the senator, I'm going to do my hair and he was probably like, great. Yeah. Well, let's take a break because when we get back, we're going to learn what our Dwight's rights are. Yes, I like it. We are back. And before we launch back into this episode, there is something that I need to do. Oh, it's something I need to do for our best friendship. I want to put something on the record. It's a good thing. It's an amazing thing.
但这很符合安吉拉·马丁的作风。我不知道。我相信她把她的化妆包和平板夹都带到医院去了。是的，我也这么觉得。我想她对参议员说，我要弄头发，而他大概会说，太好了。对。好吧，我们休息一下，因为当我们回来时，我们将了解德怀特的权利是什么。是的，我喜欢。我们回来了。在我们重新投入这一集之前，我有一件必须要做的事。哦，这是为了我们深厚的友谊我需要做的事。我想把一件事记录在案。这是一件好事。这是一件了不起的事。
Where is this coming from? I want to document it on our podcast. Today is the day that Angela's shade on her back porch that she has hated for how many years? Oh, 10 years. It's an old, ripped awning. Part of it has mildewed. It's so old and gross. It's coming down today, everybody.
这从何说起？我想把它记录在我们的播客里。今天是安吉拉后廊上那个她讨厌了多少年的遮阳篷被拆掉的日子？哦，10年。这是一个破旧、撕裂的遮阳篷。有一部分已经发霉了。它太旧太恶心了。各位，它今天就要被拆下来了。
It is coming down at 7.30 this morning. I received a video from Angela of the guys who are taking this down finally. Yeah. You all need to understand how many messages over the last 10 years I have gotten from Angela where she is venting about this shade. And you might be wondering, why has she not taken it down earlier? It's because it created like just... A domino effect.
它在今天早上7点30分被拆下来。我收到了安吉拉发来的视频，是那些终于把这东西拆下来的人。对。你们所有人都需要明白，在过去的10年里，我收到了安吉拉多少条关于这个遮阳篷的抱怨信息。你可能会想，她为什么不早点把它拆下来？因为它引发了就像……多米诺骨牌效应。
Yes. You're like, if I take it down, what am I putting up? I want to expand the back porch. I don't want to get a new shade that's too short. That'll be dumb. Yeah. Yeah, it was a whole thing. I couldn't take it down till, you know, I knew what I was going to do and save some money and got some ideas.
是的。你会想，如果我把它拆下来，我要装上什么？我想扩建后廊。我不想买一个太短的新遮阳篷。那太蠢了。对。对，这是一件大事。在我知道我要做什么、存点钱并有一些想法之前，我不能把它拆下来。
Yes, because it was a whole thing. It's a whole thing. You can't just take down the shade. No, because I have like a, you know how you just have like about three feet off your back door and then it's the yard? Yes. So I knew when I took the shade down, I wanted to do a proper porch. Mm-hmm. I'm very excited.
是的，因为这是一件大事。这是一件大事。你不能只把遮阳篷拆下来。不，因为我有一个，你知道你后门外面大概只有三英尺然后就是院子的情况吗？是的。所以我知道当我把遮阳篷拆下来时，我想做一个像样的门廊。嗯哼。我非常兴奋。
It's finally happening. It's finally happening. I mean, I almost cried when you sent me the video. I was like, I can't believe he's never going to leave me another message about the shade. It's gone. Oh, my gosh. I know. I needed it to be part of this podcast so that we could record for all time. The awning is finally coming off. Listen, while I've been here, I've been getting updates from my husband. Look at this one. I'm going to show you. Oh, my gosh. It is, it's half down.
它终于发生了。它终于发生了。我是说，当你把视频发给我时，我差点哭了。我想，我真不敢相信他再也不会给我留下关于遮阳篷的留言了。它没了。哦，天哪。我知道。我需要让它成为这个播客的一部分，这样我们就可以永久记录下来。遮阳篷终于要拆掉了。听着，当我在这里的时候，我一直在收到我丈夫的最新消息。看这个。我要给你看。哦，天哪。它是，它已经拆了一半了。
It's half down. I don't know what I'm going home to. Well, not that awning. It's a wonderful, beautiful day. Oh, man. What will take its place, I wonder? What that I gripe to you about? Yeah.
它已经拆了一半了。我不知道我回家要面对什么。嗯，绝对不是那个遮阳篷。这是一个绝妙、美丽的日子。哦，天哪。我想知道，什么会取代它？还有什么是我可以向你抱怨的？对。
Well, what is gripe number two? There isn't even anything that comes to mind. What do I do with all that extra time I'm going to get? I don't know. I'll have to leave you positive affirmations. Okay. Well, back to the episode, Dwight is asking Jim to go over the details of the case. again. He's like, I don't understand how it worked. Yeah. So he repeats back to Jim. He's like,
那么，第二个抱怨是什么？甚至没有什么能浮现在脑海中。我该怎么打发我要多出来的那些额外时间呢？我不知道。我得给你留下一些积极的肯定。好吧。好吧，回到这一集，德怀特正要求吉姆重新过一遍案件的细节。他说，我不明白它是怎么运作的。对。于是他向吉姆复述。他说，
so there was a guy and he's on his bicycle. And Jim's like, yeah. And Dwight's like, aha, you never said there was a bicycle. And he's like, I knew it. I gotcha. This is going to open up a whole can of worms because now Dwight has decided to make a citizen's arrest of Jim. Instead of reading him his Miranda rights, Dwight's going to say, you have the right to remain silent. You have the right to beg for mercy, you have the right to request judgment by combat. Dwight's rights. I love judgment by combat. I know I did too. Andy tells Dwight to take a chill pill. And literally, like he's a first grade teacher, he hands Dwight a make-believe glass of water and a make-believe pill. We had a fan catch from Brandon in Illinois who said, I have always loved the added detail of how Dwight crumbles up the fake cup when he's swallowing his chill pill.
所以有一个人，他骑着自行车。吉姆说，对。德怀特说，啊哈，你从来没说过有一辆自行车。然后他说，我早就知道了。我抓到你了。这将会引发一连串的麻烦，因为现在德怀特决定对吉姆实施公民逮捕。德怀特没有向他宣读米兰达警告，而是说，你有权保持沉默。你有权乞求怜悯，你有权要求通过决斗进行裁决。德怀特的权利。我喜欢决斗裁决。我知道我也很喜欢。安迪叫德怀特冷静点。然后，就像一个一年级老师一样，他递给德怀特一杯假想的水和一颗假想的药丸。我们收到了来自伊利诺伊州布兰登的粉丝投稿，他说，我一直很喜欢德怀特在吞下冷静药丸时把假杯子揉成一团的这个额外细节。
Yeah. That was a moment for me when I saw that. I was like, that is something we all learned to do in acting class. You had to personalize the moment. Yes, exactly. Ground it. Yeah. His acting classes just paid off in that moment. He made it very specific. Well, Dwight takes the chill pill. He's very chill now. He's very chill, but he does very calmly say, Andy, if Jim lied, will you fire him? And Andy says yes. Mm-hmm. Oh, no. Well, Jim is going to come clean to Andy. Yeah. They go into the stairwell. So many confessions have happened in this stairwell. It's where everyone goes for their heart to hearts. I know. It's very cute.
对。当我看到那个画面时，那对我来说是一个时刻。我就想，那是我们在表演课上都学过的一招。你必须把那个时刻个性化。是的，没错。把它脚踏实地。对。他的表演课在那个时刻得到了回报。他把它变得非常具体。好吧，德怀特吃下了冷静药丸。他现在非常冷静。他非常冷静，但他非常平静地问，安迪，如果吉姆撒谎了，你会解雇他吗？安迪说会。嗯哼。哦，不。好吧，吉姆要向安迪坦白了。对。他们走进了楼梯间。这个楼梯间里发生过太多次坦白了。这是每个人进行推心置腹交谈的地方。我知道。这很可爱。
I had a few heart to hearts in the stairwell. I had a big heart to heart in that stairwell. Yeah. Like, for real. For real. I'm saying for real. It kind of was funny that in episodes that were written, the characters had heart to hearts there. But actually, in real life, we did too.
我在楼梯间里进行过几次推心置腹的交谈。我在那个楼梯间里进行过一次重大的推心置腹交谈。对。真的。真的。我说的是真的。在写好的剧集中，角色们在那里进行推心置腹的交谈，这其实有点搞笑。但实际上，在现实生活中，我们也是这样的。
Mm-hmm. Jim is going to tell Andy, look, I'm sorry. I stayed home to help Pam with the kids, and I'm sorry I lied to you. I think we should just come clean. Yeah, Jim says, I should tell everybody. And Andy's like, no, no, no, no, no, no. This will be just between us. Yeah, because he doesn't want to, like, have to fire him.
嗯哼。吉姆要对安迪说，听着，我很抱歉。我留在家里帮帕姆照顾孩子，我很抱歉对你撒谎。我觉得我们应该直接坦白。对，吉姆说，我应该告诉所有人。安迪却说，不，不，不，不，不，不。这只有我们俩知道。对，因为他不想，比如说，不得不解雇他。
Yeah. He's like, I got your back. He's like, have you ever heard of a Connecticut cover up? Jim says no. Andy says, do you want to know why you never heard of it? Jim says, no, covered it up. That was a very funny couplet. I looked up Connecticut cover-up.
对。他说，我支持你。他说，你听说过康涅狄格掩盖事件吗？吉姆说没有。安迪说，你想知道为什么你从来没听说过吗？吉姆说，没有，掩盖掉了。那是非常搞笑的一句双关语。我查了一下康涅狄格掩盖事件。
I did, too. It's in the Urban Dictionary attributed to the office. Right. Yeah. Yeah. I actually texted Warren about it because he's from Connecticut. And I was like, Warren, was this you in the writer's room? He said, I can't take credit for it, but it feels like something I might have pitched.
我也查了。它被收录在城市词典里，并归功于《办公室》。对。对。我其实为此给沃伦发了短信，因为他是康涅狄格州人。我说，沃伦，这是你在编剧室里的杰作吗？他说，我可不能居功，但这听起来确实像是我可能会提出来的东西。
Well, Dwight has done something. Mm-hmm. He has hired Ernesto's food truck to come to the office. Yeah. And pinatas for everybody. Mm-hmm. I asked Steve Burgess about that food truck. He said that was a rental from studio picture vehicles. It really didn't make any food. We didn't get any impanadas. No. I wondered. Well, immediately Ernesto sees Toby. He's like, Toby. Yes. And then Jim walks out and Dwight's like, Jim, who's that? And Ernesto had no idea who he was. And Jim had no idea. Yeah. Clearly, until Toby's like, that's like, damn it. But he has a line that cracked me up. He's like, okay, he. He's. He remembers Toby the most forgettable man in the known world.
好吧，德怀特做了一件事。嗯哼。他雇了欧内斯特的餐车来到办公室。对。还有给每个人的皮纳塔。嗯哼。我向史蒂夫·伯吉斯打听了那辆餐车。他说那是从影视车辆租赁公司租来的。它根本没做任何食物。我们没有吃到任何恩帕纳达。不。我就觉得。好吧，欧内斯特一看到托比就认出来了。他说，托比。是的。然后吉姆走了出来，德怀特说，吉姆，那是谁？而欧内斯特根本不知道他是谁。吉姆也不知道。对。很明显，直到托比说，那是，该死。但他有一句台词把我逗乐了。他说，好吧，他。他是。他记得托比，已知世界上最容易被遗忘的男人。
I know. Guestar Alert, Ernesto is played by Eduardo Antonio Garcia. You might recognize him from No Country for Old Men, for which he won a SAG Award. Or Law & Order, L.A., he is also one of the most prolific voice actors in the business. He has voiced over 1,500 commercials since 1998. That's amazing. Yeah. The scene has another one of my favorite lines in the episode.
我知道。明星警报，欧内斯特由爱德华多·安东尼奥·加西亚饰演。你可能从《老无所依》中认出他，他凭借该片赢得了演员工会奖。或者《法律与秩序：洛杉矶》，他也是业内最具多产的配音演员之一。自1998年以来，他已经为1500多部商业广告配音。这太惊人了。对。这个场景里有我在这一集里最喜欢的另一句台词。
Okay. Crete says, usually I'm a burrito guy, but if you won't till I won't, wink, wink. Like, what? I just picture our writer's room just coming up with these non-sequitur, like one-liners for Creed constantly. See, this is why I'm not a writer, because I would just write the plot. Yes. There would be no of these little, like, awesome pops of flavor from different characters. All my characters would sound the same. it would just be information, information, information.
好吧。克里德说，通常我是个卷饼迷，但如果你不吃，我也不吃，眨眼。就像，什么？我脑海中浮现出的画面就是我们的编剧室不断地为克里德想出这些不着边际的、类似于单口相声的台词。你看，这就是为什么我当不了编剧，因为我只会写剧情。是的。这些来自不同角色的、微小的、棒极了的调味剂将不复存在。我所有的角色听起来都会一模一样。那将只有信息、信息、信息。
Because that's what I do best. I lay track and I get you there. But I don't know how to do all that other stuff. It's so cool. This is why we were such a good team writing our book because I would write something. You'd be like, Angie, this is really funny. This is a great memory. Where does it go?
因为那是我最擅长的。我铺设轨道，然后把你带到目的地。但我不知道怎么做所有其他那些东西。这太酷了。这就是为什么我们在写书时配合得那么默契，因为我会写点东西。你会说，安吉，这真的太好笑了。这是一个极好的回忆。它该去哪儿呢？
I'm like, I don't know. And then you'd be like, okay, here's some structure. And then you would write something. And I'd be like, Jenna, this is great. I'm going to give it a little bit of juz. Yeah, you're like, we need some jokes in here. I am in awe of writers. It's no wonder that's who I would always fall in love with.
我说，我不知道。然后你会说，好吧，这里有一些结构。接着你会写点东西。我会说，珍娜，这太棒了。我要给它加点料。对，你会说，我们这里需要一些笑话。我对编剧佩服得五体投地。难怪我总是会爱上编剧。
I always fall in love with the writers. My whole life, going back to college, going back to high school. We fall in love with the things that we feel missing in ourselves. I think you're right, Ang. Things are falling apart for Andy and Jim. It's becoming very clear. How is Andy going to keep this going? We got a fan question from Greg S in Maryland who said this episode has one of the best work-related quotes ever.
我总是爱上编剧。我的一生，从大学追溯到高中。我们会爱上那些我们在自己身上感到缺失的东西。我觉得你是对的，安吉。安迪和吉姆的情况正在分崩离析。这变得越来越明显。安迪要怎么把这场戏继续演下去？我们收到了来自马里兰州格雷格·S的粉丝提问，他说这一集包含了一条史上最佳的工作相关名言。
I am a video editor and I cannot tell you how many times I'm asked to edit something, review the footage I'm given, and I say to myself under my breath, I am not Rumble Stillskin, Jim. I can't keep spinning gold out of your shit. It's such a good line. They are such a horrible lying duo. The two of them are so bad. Now it's escalated to this story where Andy, who lives. lives by the courthouse, would drive every morning and get Jim and bring them back to the courthouse, and watch his cute tushy walk into those steps. It's become like a nightmare for them.
我是一名视频剪辑师，我简直无法数清有多少次我被要求剪辑某段视频，审阅给我的素材，然后我在心里对自己说，我不是侏儒怪，吉姆。我不能一直用你的狗屎纺出金子来。这台词太棒了。他们真是一对可怕的撒谎二人组。这俩人太糟糕了。现在事情升级到了这样一个故事：住在法院附近的安迪每天早晨开车去接吉姆，把他带到法院，看着他那可爱的屁股走进那些台阶。这成了他们的一场噩梦。
There was a Dwight talking head here that didn't make it into the episode, but I want to read it to you. Okay. Oh my gosh. Dwight says, I have a recurring nightmare that I've been wrongly accused of a crime, and 12 of these idiots are on the jury. Stanley is fast asleep. Kevin eats the evidence. Phyllis's name is Allison, but it really is Phyllis. Jim is foreman of the jury and pronounces me guilty. The cop takes me away and tells me that I've been a bad boy, and we have sex in the hall. She leaves the handcuffs on. They take me away to prison. The guards are all women. And then he goes, ha, that went places I wasn't expecting. I know. And I had to wonder, too, if somewhere embedded
这里原本有一个德怀特的单人镜头，没有剪进这一集里，但我想读给你听。好的。哦，天哪。德怀特说，我有一个反复出现的噩梦，梦见我被诬告犯了罪，而陪审团由这12个白痴组成。斯坦利睡得正香。凯文把证据吃掉了。菲利斯的名字叫艾利森，但实际上她就是菲利斯。吉姆是陪审团长，并宣告我有罪。警察把我带走，告诉我我一直是个坏男孩，我们在大厅里做爱。她把手铐留在了手上。他们把我带到监狱。狱警全部都是女性。然后他说，哈，事情的发展超出了我的预期。我知道。而且我也不禁纳闷，在某个地方是否潜藏着
and there was a little shout out to the fact that Allison and Phyllis worked together. Oh, yes, Allison Joan. Yep. Hmm. Well, should we go back to the hospital? Yeah, because Aaron is holding baby Philip, and she says, you know, I think Philip might be more than five pounds because that's the weight that I squat with. And the senator just says, oh, he's nine pounds. Yes, and Angela's like, oh, I don't, well, I don't remember.
其中暗含对艾利森和菲利斯一起工作这一事实的一个小致敬。哦，是的，艾利森·琼。没错。嗯。好吧，我们要不要回医院看看？对，因为艾伦抱着小菲利普，她说，你知道，我觉得菲利普可能不止五磅，因为那是我深蹲时的重量。而参议员只是说，哦，他有九磅。是的，而安吉拉却说，哦，我不知道，好吧，我不记得了。
Well, Angela makes up an excuse for remembering it. wrong. You know, she was on so many drugs. Yeah, she might as well have been at a James Taylor concert. Yeah. Well, now Oscar and Kevin are going to give Angela some gifts that they brought for baby Philip. We got a fan question from Kelly T in Indiana who says, when Oscar gives Angela the present at the hospital, it is in the classic movie present box, a wrapped box and a wrapped lid that lifts off. I have never seen a gift like this in real life. Do they do this because of the sound of ripping wrapping paper? Why not a gift bag? Kelly, I will tell you. It is for many reasons. One, it's the ripped wrapping paper. Yes. Well, yeah, the sound. Remember the faky bag. That's why we never can
好吧，安吉拉为自己记错时间找了个借口。你知道，她当时用了太多的药。对，她当时的状态简直就像在听詹姆斯·泰勒的音乐会一样。好吧，现在奥斯卡和凯文要给安吉拉送一些他们为小菲利普带来的礼物。我们收到了来自印第安纳州凯利·T的粉丝提问，他说，当奥斯卡在医院把礼物送给安吉拉时，它在一个经典的电影礼物盒里，一个带盖子的包装盒，盖子可以提起来。我在现实生活中从来没见过这样的礼物。他们这样做是因为撕包装纸的声音吗？为什么不用礼品袋呢？凯利，我来告诉你。这是出于很多原因。第一，是撕包装纸的声音。是的。好吧，对，那个声音。还记得那个假袋子吗。这就是为什么我们永远不能
carry a real shopping bag. You have to carry the faky bag. But also, this way, they could just put the gift in and put the top back on, and they didn't have to, like, have a bunch of pre-wrapped gifts with a onesie inside of it. Also, you could do multiple tapes. Exactly. And also, if it was wrapped, every time Oscar unwrapped it, he would have to unwrap it exactly the same. So the continuity would match. And you're never going to be able to unwrap it exactly the same. No, exactly. And a gift bag with tissue paper, I mean, no, that's bad for sound. So Oscar gives Angela this gift and it's a teeny tiny, preemie onesie. Yeah. It's clearly not going to fit that baby. No. And Kevin gives Angela's baby call of duty. Mm-hmm. Well, I went on office telly.com and I found a link for this episode called Angela is miffed by the gifts. And it is a series of photos with snarky captions written by Angela Martin. Here is what it says. While I'm not surprised my coworkers gave me gifts for the arrival of my baby, I asked them to. I am simply shocked and appalled by some of them. So the first photo is of a tiny yellow knitted sweater. And it says,
拿一个真正的购物袋。你必须拿那个假袋子。但同时，这样一来，他们只要把礼物放进去，再把盖子盖上就行了，而不必准备一堆预先包装好的礼物，里面还得塞一件婴儿连体衣。此外，你可以使用多层胶带。没错。而且，如果它是包装好的，奥斯卡每次拆开时都必须以完全相同的方式拆开。这样连贯性才能匹配上。而你永远无法做到以完全相同的方式拆开它。不，完全正确。里面有棉纸的礼品袋，我是说，不，这对收音效果不好。所以奥斯卡送给安吉拉这个礼物，是一件极小的、早产儿穿的连体衣。对。这显然不适合那个婴儿。不。凯文送给安吉拉的婴儿礼物是《使命召唤》。嗯哼。好吧，我上了officetally.com网站，找到了这一集的一个链接，叫做“安吉拉对礼物感到生气”。这是一系列照片，配有安吉拉·马丁写的一些刻薄的说明文字。内容如下。虽然同事们为我婴儿的到来送我礼物并不让我意外，我甚至要求他们这么做了。但我对其中的一些礼物感到无比震惊和骇然。第一张照片是一件织得极小的黄色毛衣。上面写着，
Phyllis decided it would be a good idea to make the baby and I matching wool sweaters. I'm sorry, are we Irish hippies? Hardly. Think. And then there's more. I guess Aaron gave you generic baby bottles. Meredith dropped off a $12 gift certificate to Arby's and some beer. Andy gave Angela a very nice silver rattle.
菲利斯觉得让婴儿和我穿同款羊毛衫是个好主意。抱歉，我们是爱尔兰嬉皮士吗？怎么可能。想想看。还有更多的。我猜艾伦送了你普通的婴儿奶瓶。梅雷迪思送了一张12美元的阿比斯餐馆礼品卡和一些啤酒。安迪送给安吉拉一个非常漂亮的银色拨浪鼓。
Angela liked this. She said that Philip would hold it in their first family portrait. So you were quite surprised. Creed gave Angela Martin a swearing parrot. A real-life parrot? Yeah. A real-life swearing parrot. You know, the screaming parrot thing is pretty amazing.
安吉拉很喜欢这个。她说菲利普会在他们的第一张全家福里拿着它。所以你相当惊讶。克里德送给安吉拉·马丁一只会说脏话的鹦鹉。一只现实生活中的鹦鹉？对。一只现实生活中的会说脏话的鹦鹉。你知道，那个尖叫的鹦鹉的桥段相当神奇。
I remember when they were doing those. Yeah. This is what kind of cracks me up because, you know, if you go to what Pam's blog was and then what Angela's, like how they document their babies and stuff, it's very different. Yes, Angela's blog was basically like a great. Shame her coworkers. Shame list. But this did get me thinking, how could they have done better? So I was a lady who Googled, and I found a list of gifts you can give a coworker who's having a baby.
我记得他们拍那些的时候。对。这正是让我觉得搞笑的地方，因为，你知道的，如果你去看看帕姆的博客是什么样，然后看看安吉拉的——比如他们是如何记录他们的婴儿之类的，那是完全不同的。是的，安吉拉的博客基本上就像一个巨大的羞辱同事黑名单。羞辱名单。但这确实让我思考，他们本可以怎么做更好？所以我这个女士去谷歌了一下，我找到了一份你可以送给生了婴儿的同事的礼物清单。
This list was on lovto know.com, and it suggested that if you're in an office, you can pool your money and then buy one of the following gifts. And lady, I have to say, I thought these were all brilliant. Okay. I'm going to keep these in the back of my mind for anyone who has a... baby in the future. Okay, let's hear them. Number one, a baby bathtub filled with health and toiletry items like washcloths and baby soap and baby first aid supplies. Love it. So cute. Number two, a big ticket item like a stroller or a high chair or a breast pump. Number three, diapers. Just load them up with a bunch of size one, size two diapers and wipes.
这份清单来自lovto know.com，它建议如果你在办公室里，大家可以凑钱然后购买以下礼物之一。而这位女士，我不得不说，我觉得这些都太绝了。好吧。我会把这些记在心底，以防将来有人生婴儿。好吧，说来听听。第一，一个装满了健康和洗漱用品的婴儿浴盆，比如洗脸巾、婴儿肥皂和婴儿急救用品。太棒了。太可爱了。第二，一件大件物品，比如婴儿车、高脚椅或吸奶器。第三，纸尿裤。直接给他们准备一大堆一号、二号纸尿裤和湿巾。
Number four, a baby basket of board books. Oh, cute. Like kind of going up through the ages. And finally, a gift certificate for a photo shoot with an infant photographer. What a good idea is that. Yeah. Right? I love it.
第四，一篮子婴儿硬纸板书。哦，可爱。就像随着年龄增长而不同阶段的书。最后，是一张婴儿摄影师拍摄写真的礼品券。这是多么棒的一个主意啊。对。对吧？我太喜欢了。
I loved all of them. I will add one thing to it that I received, which was a mommy spa day. Ooh. That's a good one. Yeah, a little something for mom, too. Mm-hmm. Oscar's going to have a very funny talking head where he says, This baby is clearly not premature.
我太喜欢所有这些了。我要在里面补充一件我收到过的礼物，那就是妈妈水疗日。哦。那个真不错。对，也给妈妈一点小福利。嗯哼。奥斯卡将有一个非常搞笑的单人镜头，他说，这个婴儿显然不是早产儿。
They're lying about the date it was conceived. It's very interesting. And her husband's gay. I don't even know which thread to follow. You mentioned how good Oscar is in this episode, this talking head again. So good. So good. I love how giddy he is.
他们在孕育日期上撒谎了。这太有趣了。而且她丈夫是个同性恋。我甚至不知道该顺着哪条线索追查下去。你提到了奥斯卡在这一集里表现得有多好，又是这个单人镜头。太棒了。太棒了。我喜欢他那种欣喜若狂的样子。
He's discovered. I know. Back at the office, without telling Andy first, Jim calls everyone's attention and apologizes for the burden of last week. and then he tells them that he wasn't really on jury duty, he was home with Pam. I mean, Dwight's delighted. He's like, bye-bye, starts packing up his stuff. Yes, but he's putting work stuff in a box. Did you notice he takes a box and he starts immediately packing up what looks like work? It's not even Jim's personal items. It doesn't make any sense. People are mad at Jim. They're giving him the stink eye. Well, there was a deleted Jim and Pam scene
他发现了。我知道。回到办公室，在没有先告诉安迪的情况下，吉姆吸引了所有人的注意，并为上周给大家带来的负担道歉。然后他告诉大家，他其实并没有去参加陪审团陪审，他是留在家里陪帕姆了。我是说，德怀特高兴坏了。他说，拜拜，开始收拾他的东西。是的，但他把工作用品塞进了一个箱子。你注意到他拿了一个箱子，并开始立即收拾看起来像工作用品的东西了吗？那甚至不是吉姆的个人物品。这根本说不通。大家都在生吉姆的气。他们都在狠狠地瞪他。好吧，有一个被删掉的吉姆和帕姆的场景
that sets up why they ultimately bring the kids to work. Oh, tell me. I have no memory of this. I was in a fog. Well, you were on the phone, so maybe. Okay. This was a call-in scene for you, lady. So there was a deleted Jim storyline where he tries to win everyone over, and it starts with his talking head. Here's what he says. I would love for everyone to just forgive me, but if that's not happening, I'm not averse to just buying them off. Okay. And then you see him going into the break room and buying all the red licorice in the vending machine. And he makes a big announcement to the bullpen. He says, all right, you guys, you know how we all like the red licorice, but it's always buried behind a ton of the black licorice. Well, guess what? I bought it all. Now it's like red city in there. So enjoy. And he has
它为他们最终把孩子带到办公室做好了铺垫。哦，快告诉我。我对此毫无记忆。我当时脑子一片混乱。好吧，你当时在打电话，所以也许吧。好吧，女士，这是一个需要你出声的场景。所以原本有一个被删掉的吉姆的故事线，他试图赢得所有人的原谅，故事从他的单人镜头开始。他是这么说的。我很想让所有人都能原谅我，但如果做不到的话，我不介意用钱把他们买通。好吧。然后你看到他走进茶水间，把自动售货机里的所有红甘草糖都买了下来。他向大办公室做了一个重大宣布。他说，好了，伙计们，你们知道我们都喜欢红甘草糖，但它总是埋在一堆黑甘草糖后面。好吧，猜怎么着？我把它全买下来了。现在里面就像是红色之城了。所以尽情享用吧。然后他
all the licorice, right? For them? Phyllis is like, mm-hmm, money bags must be nice. Oh, boy. Andy said, so you effectively spent, what, $4 on the entire office? And Jim's like, I can't get a handle on it. Am I cheap or rich? I can't. And then Andy's like, you're nothing. When I think about all the gas money, I spent on you washing my car to make sure he, like, Andy is just so determined to keep his lie going. Yes.
把所有的甘草糖都拿来了，对吧？给他们的？菲利斯说，嗯哼，财大气粗，真是不错呢。哦，天哪。安迪说，所以你实际上花了，什么，4美元买下了整个办公室？吉姆却说，我实在搞不懂了。我是小气还是富有？我搞不懂。然后安迪说，你什么都不是。当我想到我为了洗你的车在你身上花了多少汽油钱，以确保他——安迪就是这么坚决地要把他的谎言继续演下去。是的。
Jim interrupts him and says, enjoy the licorice, everyone. Everyone continues giving Jim a lot of grief about this red licorice stunt, right? They're all turning on him. Creed, Stanley, Daryl. In the next scene, Jim has gone down to Dwight's gym for muscles. Oh, wow. He's riding the bicycle and eating red licorice by himself. He calls Pam and says, They hate me, Pam. Pam says, they don't hate you. Jim goes, no, it's bad. Daryl canceled go-karting. Pam goes, when were you going go-karting with Daryl? Jim says, it's a lunch thing. Pam says, all right, just don't worry, we'll figure this out. Jim says, I feel like a stranger in my own country. Pam says,
吉姆打断他说，大家享用甘草糖吧。每个人继续因为这个红甘草糖的噱头而给吉姆找很多麻烦，对吧？他们都在背叛他。克里德、斯坦利、达里尔。在下一个场景中，吉姆来到了德怀特的肌肉健身房。哦，哇。他独自一人骑着自行车，吃着红甘草糖。他打电话给帕姆说，他们讨厌我，帕姆。帕姆说，他们不讨厌你。吉姆说，不，情况很糟。达里尔取消了卡丁车活动。帕姆说，你打算什么时候和达里尔去开卡丁车？吉姆说，这是一个午餐局。帕姆说，好吧，别担心，我们会搞定的。吉姆说，我觉得自己在自己的国家里像个陌生人。帕姆说，
okay, drama. And then Jim goes, hey, you're not here. You don't know, okay? It's intense. They made me eat black licorish. Wow. And then I guess Pam's plan is let's bring the kids. Oh my gosh. But I thought it was really funny when you go, okay, drama. Well, back at the hospital, Angela's going to come clean. So Jim has come clean. So Jim has come clean. in the office. Now Angela's going to come clean. She's going to tell everybody, listen, this baby was conceived nine months ago, despite our intention to wait, but you'd just seen Thor and there was too much wine in her chicken piccata. Chicken Marcella. Okay, fan catch from Alex P and Katie G. And many others, when Angela finally admits that she and the senator conceived Philip out of wedlock,
好吧，戏真多。然后吉姆说，嘿，你又不在。你根本不懂，好吗？这很紧张。他们逼我吃黑甘草糖。哇。然后我猜帕姆的计划就是把孩子们带来。哦，天哪。但我觉得当你脱口而出“好吧，戏真多”时，真的很好笑。好吧，回到医院，安吉拉要坦白了。所以吉姆已经在办公室坦白了。现在轮到安吉拉坦白了。她要告诉所有人，听着，这个婴儿是九个月前怀上的，尽管我们原本打算再等等，但你刚看完《雷神》，而且她的鸡肉比卡塔里有太多的酒。鸡肉马沙拉。好吧，来自亚历克斯·P和凯蒂·G的粉丝纠错。还有许多其他人，当安吉拉最终承认她和参议员在婚前怀上菲利普时，
She says there was too much wine in her chicken. But isn't Angela a vegetarian? Great catch. Great catch. Mm-hmm. This scene does have one of my favorite lines in the entire episode, which is when Oscar says, The only premature baby in this room is the baby this baby ate. Well, guess who's going to come meet this baby now?
她说鸡肉里有太多的酒。但安吉拉不是素食主义者吗？抓得好。抓得好。嗯哼。这个场景确实有一句我在整集中最喜欢的台词，那就是当奥斯卡说，这个房间里唯一的早产儿是被这个婴儿吃掉的那个婴儿。好吧，猜猜现在是谁要来看这个婴儿了？
Dwight. He's come to the hospital looking for Gabe. Yeah. He's not even interested in seeing the baby until Oscar tells him, I promised I wouldn't say anything. And then he goes, so don't. I know I loved that. And then Oscar tells him.
德怀特。他来到医院寻找盖比。对。他甚至对看婴儿不感兴趣，直到奥斯卡告诉他，我答应过我什么都不会说的。然后他说，那就别说。我知道，我太喜欢那个了。然后奥斯卡告诉了他。
And then Oscar goes, I didn't tell you. And Dwight goes, yes, you did. That made me laugh so hard. Well, Dwight barges into Angela's hospital room, demands to see the baby. I spotted a little something on the whiteboard as Dwight was entering the room. There's a little hospital whiteboard, you know, and it says that Angela's nurse's name is Ruth Scher. So I asked Erin Scher, a writer about it, and he said that was his wife at the time. She was becoming a nurse at the age of 50, and that she has now gone on to become a family
然后奥斯卡说，我可没告诉你。德怀特说，不，你说了。这把我逗得哈哈大笑。好吧，德怀特闯进安吉拉的病房，要求看婴儿。当德怀特进门时，我在白板上发现了一个小细节。有一个小医院白板，你知道的，上面写着安吉拉的护士名叫露丝·谢尔。所以我去问了编剧艾伦·谢尔关于这件事，他说那是他当时的妻子。她50岁时开始成为一名护士，现在已经成了一名家庭
nurse practitioner, and he was just very proud. So he put her name up on the board as Angela's nurse. I love it. So now Dwight is looking at little baby Philip Halstead Lipton. Halstead, which was one of our writers, I said to Halstead, Did you pitch to have your name in this episode? He goes, no, quite the opposite. I was like, no, you guys. But like the writer's room insisted. When Dwight sees the baby, I thought the baby looked like Dwight. They did a great job casting these babies. It's true. Yeah. Although in a later scene, Angela is going to say, your face looks like a baby. Dwight. That was one of my favorite lines to say. So maybe any baby looks like Rayne Wilson, but they did a good job. I think there's three categories of babies. Oh, yeah? Yes.
护士执业师，他对此感到非常骄傲。所以他把她的名字写在白板上作为安吉拉的护士。我太喜欢了。现在德怀特正看着小婴儿菲利普·哈尔斯特德·利普顿。哈尔斯特德，这是我们的一位编剧，我对哈尔斯特德说，你是不是提议把你的名字写进这一集里？他说，不，恰恰相反。我就像，不，你们这些家伙。但编剧室坚持要这么做。当德怀特看到婴儿时，我觉得这个婴儿长得像德怀特。他们在挑选这些婴儿方面做得太棒了。确实如此。是的。尽管在后来的场景中，安吉拉会说，你的脸看起来像个婴儿，德怀特。那是我最喜欢说的一句台词之一。所以也许任何婴儿看起来都像雷恩·威尔逊，但他们确实干得漂亮。我觉得婴儿可以分为三类。哦，是吗？是的。
There are chubber babies, uh-huh, old man babies. Yeah. And baby babies. These are the three categories of babies. You get like a baby that just looks like a baby. Just a baby. Yeah.
有胖乎乎婴儿，嗯哼，老头子婴儿。对。还有真正的婴儿。这就是婴儿的三类。你会看到一个看起来就像个普通婴儿的婴儿。就是一个婴儿。对。
Just baby baby. And then there's like old man baby. Yeah. Where it's a baby that looks like an old man shrunken down. Right. So cute. And then there's chubber baby where it's just like rolls and rolls of chubber baby. on the baby.
纯粹的婴儿。然后还有像老头子婴儿这种。对，就是那种看起来像个缩小型老头的婴儿。太可爱了。然后还有胖乎乎婴儿，就是婴儿身上有一圈又一圈的肉的那种胖乎乎婴儿。
I can't get enough of all these babies. I love all the babies. I know. They're so cute. Well, it's going to be time to breastfeed the baby, which is, you know, the senator's cue to leave. He's like, I'm out. Dwight wraps the curtain around them.
我对所有这些婴儿简直爱不释手。我爱所有的婴儿。我知道。他们太可爱了。好吧，差不多该给婴儿喂奶了，你知道的，这就是参议员离开的信号。他说，我撤了。德怀特把窗帘围在他们周围。
And I have to tell you, this scene that I got to do with Rain was one of my most fun scenes from being on the show because we knew our characters so well. And they had scripted the top half of the scene. And then our director, Eric, just loved. let us go and interrupt each other and play around until it just felt like a true argument where you're kind of stepping on each other and it didn't feel scripted at all to me. Even though I knew the first part of it was because they let us play around so much with it and kept some of our improv in, I just thought the scene turned out so great. It is a great example of your chemistry
我必须告诉你，我和雷恩一起演的这个场景是我在剧中觉得最好玩的场景之一，因为我们太了解我们的角色了。剧本里写了前半部分的场景。然后我们的导演埃里克特别喜欢放手让我们互相打断、自由发挥，直到它感觉像是一场真正的争吵，你们有点在抢对方的词，而且对我来说这感觉一点也不像照着剧本演的。尽管我知道第一部分是照剧本演的，因为他们让我们自由发挥了很多，并且保留了我们的一些即兴表演，但我真的觉得这个场景呈现出来的效果太棒了。这绝对是你俩化学反应的一个绝佳范例。
together. Like it just sings. Sometimes a scene just sings and this one did. It was so good Thanks, lady. I loved doing it. You want to guess where the scripted part stopped and we started improvising? Did you improvise the line? Your face looks like a baby? No, that was written and it was such a great line. So after Dwight says, and then I kissed you with the force of a thousand waterfalls, and Angela says, that didn't happen. Everything after that was improvised. Oh, amazing. When Dwight said, and then I inserted my penis and I say, nope. Stop it. Like, I had no idea that that was going to be said. And then Dwight continues into year, and I'm like, Dwight. He goes, Vagina, aunt, and I'm like, even if it did, it's a coincidence. That was such a great line. He's like, there is a chance. I was like, admitted. I'm like, I will not.
就像它简直在发光。有时一个场景就是会发光，而这个就是。太棒了。谢谢你，女士。我演得很过瘾。你想猜猜剧本部分在哪里结束、我们从哪里开始即兴发挥的吗？你即兴发挥了那句台词吗？你的脸看起来像个婴儿？不，那是写好的台词，而且是一句绝佳的台词。所以在德怀特说，然后我以千股瀑布的力量吻了你，而安吉拉说，那没有发生。之后的一切全都是即兴发挥的。哦，太惊艳了。当德怀特说，然后我插入了我的阴茎，而我说，不。住手。就像，我根本不知道他会说出那样的话。然后德怀特继续说到年，而我说，德怀特。他说，阴道，蚂蚁，而我说，就算真的发生了，那也是个巧合。那台词太棒了。他说，是有这种可能的。我说，承认了吧。我说，我才不呢。
All of that was us playing around. Oh, so good. We basically got to play until they sent the senator back in. But, you know, we could do that because these characters were so well written. And we knew who they were. We knew what they would say to each other no matter what. Yeah. That was the magic of the show, right? Mm-hmm. They could write us so well and we knew ourselves so well. Well, Dwight is going to just burst out of the doors. He tells a nurse, cancel the circumcision. Yeah.
所有这些都是我们在自由发挥。哦，太棒了。我们基本上一直玩到他们把参议员重新派进来。但是，你知道的，我们能做到这一点，是因为这些角色的剧本写得太好了。我们知道他们是谁。不管发生什么，我们都知道他们会对彼此说些什么。是的。这就是这部剧的魔力所在，对吧？嗯哼。他们能把我们的剧本写得那么好，而我们也对自己那么了解。好吧，德怀特猛地冲出门外。他对护士说，取消割礼。对。
I just might be that baby's dad. The nurse is like, I don't know what that means. Yeah. By the way, the nurse was played by Carrie Clifford. She is a very funny actor as well as a producer and writer. she was absolutely brilliant in this exchange. Carrie's hilarious. She's one of those people that is funny just reading the phone book. Yeah.
我可能就是那个婴儿的爸爸。护士说，我不知道你在说什么。顺便说一句，护士是由嘉莉·克利福德饰演的。她不仅是一位非常搞笑的演员，还是一位制片人和编剧。她在这段对话中表现得绝对惊艳。嘉莉太搞笑了。她是那种光是读电话簿都能把人逗笑的人。对。
She's just got a very funny delivery. She's so very naturally funny. I know. I know. Yeah. Should we go back to the office and check in on what's happening there? Yes. Oh, please, because I have something really fun to share.
她有一种非常搞笑的说话腔调。她就是那种极其自然的搞笑。我知道。我懂。是的。我们是不是应该回到办公室，看看那里发生了什么？对。哦，拜访一下吧，因为我有一个非常有趣的事情要分享。
So there is a deleted scene that happens back at the office because Andy is determined to keep his lie going. Like he is not going to admit that he lied to help Jim. He goes to such great depths. Are you ready for this? Yes. A police officer walks into the office. Andy introduces him as Officer Foley from the Scranton PD. He said Officer Foley works down at the courthouse and he has something he'd like to say.
所以有一个被删掉的场景发生在办公室里，因为安吉拉——不对，是安迪决心把谎言继续演下去。就像他绝不承认自己是为了帮吉姆而撒谎一样。他付出了巨大的努力。你准备好听这个了吗？是的。一名警官走进了办公室。安迪把他介绍为来自斯克兰顿警察局的弗利警官。他说弗利警官在法院工作，他有话要说。
What is going on? Yeah. Officer Foley says, I understand that some of you don't believe that Mr. Bernard drove his friend into the courthouse for jury duty last week. Daryl says, correction, we don't care. Aaron says, wait, aren't you an actor? Andy's like, no. Erin goes, yeah, weren't you in Sweeney Todd last year with Andy?
这到底是怎么回事？是的。弗利警官说，我听说你们有些人不相信伯纳德先生上周开车送他的朋友去法院参加陪审团陪审。达里尔说，更正一下，我们根本不在乎。艾伦说，等等，你不是演员吗？安迪说，不是。艾伦说，不对，你去年不是和安迪一起演过《理发师陶德》吗？
And Officer Foley's like, uh, no. And Daryl goes, you hired your actor friend to come here as a cop? And Andy says, that is so offensive and ridiculous. Daryl says, so if I started singing down by the old mill stream, you couldn't and join me in a three-part harmony? And Andy and Officer Foley are like, no. And then Daryl starts singing. And immediately, Andy, Daryl, and Officer Foley had the most beautiful harmony. And they sing sort of like a barbershop quartet. And at the end, Andy goes, ah, shoot. Well, I really think we need to hear Officer Foley, Andy and Daryl sing. And when I traded emails with Aaron Scher about this episode,
弗利警官说，呃，没有。达里尔说，你雇了你的演员朋友来这里假扮警察？安迪说，这太冒犯、太荒谬了。达里尔说，所以如果我开始唱《沿着老磨坊河》，你就不能和我进行三声部和声吗？安迪和弗利警官异口同声地说，不能。然后达里尔开始唱歌。紧接着，安迪、达里尔和弗利警官唱出了最美妙的和声。他们唱得有点像四重唱。最后，安吉拉——哦不，最后安迪说，啊，糟了。好吧，我真的很想听听弗利警官、安迪和达里尔唱歌。当我跟艾伦·谢尔通过电子邮件聊到这一集时，
this was a scene we spoke about. Down by the old mill stream when I first met you down by the old stream. When I first met you. Down by the old stream. Gosh, I love that. Isn't it great? And Andy has such this pure joy reaction. He's like, yeah.
这是我们讨论过的一个场景。沿着老磨坊河，当我第一次遇见你，沿着老磨坊河。当我第一次遇见你。沿着老磨坊河。天哪，我太喜欢那个了。是不是很棒？而安迪的反应带着这种纯粹的喜悦。他说，耶。
And then he goes, ah, shoot. Busted. I know who played Officer Foley. So do I. It was our script supervisor's husband. Yes, it was Veda's husband, Michael Tuba Hetherington. I mean, Tuba was one of our recurring characters. Yes, they sounded so good together.
然后他说，啊，糟了。露馅了。我知道是谁扮演了弗利警官。我也知道。那是我们的剧务总监的丈夫。是的，那是维达的丈夫，迈克尔·图巴·黑瑟林顿。我是说，图巴是我们的常驻角色之一。是的，他们俩的声音配合得太好了。
I know. You know they had fun doing that. Oh, my gosh. I bet they rehearsed and just were having the best time. Well, down in the parking lot, Pam has arrived with the two children. Yeah. And Jim is helping her unload the kids from the car. But then Jim's going to go back up into the office and pretend,
我知道。你知道他们演得很开心。哦，天哪。我敢打赌他们排练过，而且玩得最开心了。好吧，回到停车场，帕姆带着两个孩子到了。对。吉姆在帮她把孩子们从车上抱下来。但接着吉姆要回到办公室里假装，
Like, he has no idea that Pam is there, as if she's surprised. Surprise. So I remember something about this moment, Angela, because Pam walks in pushing a stroller with baby Philip. And at the table read for this, it was scripted that she was carrying him in his car seat. I was on speakerphone for this. And I guess afterwards, Angela, you went up to Phil Shea and you said, Jedda can't carry car seat.
就好像他完全不知道帕姆在那儿，表现得好像很惊喜一样。惊喜。所以关于这个时刻我记得一件事，安吉拉，因为帕姆推着装着小菲利普的婴儿车走了进来。在这一集的剧本围读时，剧本里写的是她用汽车安全座椅抱着他。我当时在用免提电话。我猜在那之后，安吉拉，你走到菲尔·谢伊面前说，珍娜不能提那个安全座椅。
No. She's not allowed. She can't carry that. That's too heavy. You were like on it. You talk about like how the women cared for me in this episode. You were like, no, no, no. You told everybody she can't do that.
不。她不允许。她不能提那个。那太重了。你当时简直全神贯注。你谈到女性在这集里是如何照顾我的时候。你就说，不，不，不。你告诉所有人她不能做那个。
She has to have a stroller. Yes, because Phil Shea called me and he said, Jenna, is it true that you can't carry a car seat? I said, that's right. I'm still in that phase of postpartum. You had stitches. I had stitches still. They hadn't been removed. And you can't carry more than like a bag of flower, right?
她必须得用婴儿车。是的，因为菲尔·希尔打电话给我，他说，珍娜，你真的不能抱安全座椅吗？我说，没错。我还在产后的那个阶段。你缝过针。我当时还在缝着针。线还没拆呢。而且你搬的东西不能超过一袋面粉，对吧？
That's what they say. You can carry your baby, and that's about it. Yeah. So he said, can you push a stroller? I said, I can push a stroller. But I'll tell you what, I'm pushing that stroller with one arm because I was holding on to the hand of Little Cece. And that was not easy, actually, at that point. Yeah, because you're getting cold.
人们都这么说。你能抱着你的宝宝，也就仅此而已了。是的。所以他说，你能推婴儿车吗？我说，我能推婴儿车。但我告诉你，我推那个婴儿车只用了一只胳膊，因为我另一只手牵着小西西。说实话，当时那可真不容易。是的，因为你开始变凉了。
Yeah. Yeah. I went up to Phil Shane and was like, eh, er. And I didn't feel like I needed to announce it to the room because I knew Phil would just make it happen. He would just take care of me. Yeah. He did. Well, guess what?
对。对。我走到菲尔·希尔面前，说，呃，额。我觉得没必要向全场宣布，因为我知道菲尔会搞定的。他会照顾好我的。是的。他确实做到了。好吧，你猜怎么着？
Cece made everyone a picture. This made me laugh so hard. I cracked up when Ryan is like, why am I smaller than the desk? And then the look between Jim and Pam. Uh-huh. I know. Because clearly, Pam has made these drawings. Yes.
西西为每个人画了一幅画。这把我逗得哈哈大笑。当瑞安说“为什么我比桌子还矮？”时，我笑喷了。然后是吉姆和帕姆之间的眼神交流。嗯哼。我知道。因为显然，这些画都是帕姆画的。是的。
Yeah. And they're handing them out. And I love, I love when Kelly is like, did you make this drawing? And Cici's like, no. Uh-huh. And Pam's like she says no to everything. She loves to say no. Well, it's very clear that Cece did not make these drawings.
是的。他们正在把画发给大家。而且我最喜欢、最喜欢凯莉说“这画是你画的吗？”而西西说“不是”的时候。嗯哼。帕姆说她对什么都说“不”。她最喜欢说“不”了。好吧，很显然西西并没有画这些画。
And then everything sort of erupts into chaos. Yeah. Cici starts crying. And then the baby starts crying. And then I thought Daryl had the best talking head when he was like, look, I'm a dad. Those five days at home for gym, that was no vacation. Yeah. Everyone just gets it.
然后一切都陷入了一片混乱。是的。西西开始哭。然后宝宝也开始哭。然后我觉得达里尔的那段访谈镜头最棒，他说，听着，我是一个爸爸。吉姆在家的那五天，那可不是什么假期。是的。每个人都懂。
We got a fan question from Jesse W. in Alabama and many others who wanted to know how we filmed the scene with Cece being upset and crying. How does that work in show business? Yeah. Well, basically what happened was her mom had been on set with us while we were filming and her mom stepped away for a second and she started to cry and we captured it. Yeah. And then her mom came on very quickly. There's a lot of movie magic involved. Like you might notice like when she's running around in the conference room, you only see the back of her.
我们收到了来自阿拉巴马州的杰西·W以及许多其他人的粉丝提问，他们想知道我们是怎么拍摄西西心烦哭泣的那场戏的。在影视行业里这是怎么做到的？对。嗯，基本上发生的情况是，我们在拍摄时她的妈妈一直和我们在一起，她妈妈走开了一小会儿，她就开始哭了，而我们捕捉到了这一幕。是的。然后她妈妈很快就过来了。这里面有很多电影魔术。比如你可能会注意到，当她在会议室里跑来跑去时，你只能看到她的背影。
head. She was not upset. Right. She was actually having fun and we added the crying into the background. Yeah. Same with Philip. Like Phillips pacifier fell out of his mouth for a second and he started fussing and I basically put it right back in and then they just put crying noises on it. Yeah. But Cece was upset for a second. Yeah. And you can see me in the scene reach down because I'm her mom. Yeah. You know, fictionally. And I normally would have picked her up. Yeah, but you couldn't. I couldn't pick her up. I couldn't pick her up. Yeah, because those little girls, I've said before, they were played by Bailey and Sienna Stroll. We spent a lot of time with them, John and I. Yeah, that's what you do. When you're working with a baby or a toddler, you go early, you get to know the parents, you spend time with them so that when the cameras are rolling, you've had a little time to get to know each other.
头。她并没有不高兴。对。她其实玩得很开心，我们把哭声加在了背景音里。是的。菲利普也是如此。就像菲利普的安抚奶嘴从嘴里掉出来一会儿，他就开始闹腾，我基本上立刻把它塞了回去，然后他们就在上面加上了哭声。是的。不过西西确实难过了一会儿。是的。而且你能在镜头里看到我伸手向下，因为我是她妈妈。是的。你知道的，虚构的。我通常会把她抱起来。是的，但你不能。我抱不动她。我抱不动她。对，因为这两个小女孩，我之前说过，她们是由贝利和西耶娜·斯特罗尔扮演的。我和约翰花了很多时间陪她们。是的，这就是你该做的。当你和婴儿或幼儿合作时，你要早点去，去了解父母，花时间陪伴他们，这样当镜头开拍时，你们就已经花了一些时间来了解彼此了。
They were very familiar with us. Yeah. And if I could have, I would have just swooped down and picked her up. And they loved us. We had a really good relationship with them. I know. They were so sweet. So Jim is going to walk Pam and the kids out, and everyone's like, you know what, just go home, buddy.
她们对我们非常熟悉。是的。如果可以的话，我早就一把将她抱起来了。而且她们很喜欢我们。我们和她们建立了很好的关系。我懂的。她们太可爱了。所以吉姆要送帕姆和孩子们出门，大家都说，你知道吗，伙计，回家吧。
Yeah. Just go home. Everyone kind of forgives him in this moment when they see what he was really home with all week. Yeah. I have something kind of juicy to share. What? Well, in the shooting draft, there was a must shoot talking head with Kathy and a must shoot alt. I'm going to read them both to you.
对。就回家吧。当大家看到他整整一周在家里面对的到底是什么时，在这时都有点原谅他了。是的。我有点劲爆的内容想分享。什么？好吧，在拍摄剧本中，有一场凯西的必拍访谈镜头和一个必拍的替代版本。我把这两个都读给你们听。
That would have gone right here? Yeah. Okay. Ready? Yes. Oh, the message boards would have gone crazy. So there would have been a little spy shot here of Kathy talking on her cell phone to one of her friends. Really? Uh-huh. Guess what she says. What? I'm out of a job as soon as Pam gets tired of those brats. Hey, maybe I should be her nanny. My friend's a nanny. We could hang out at the park together. Oh, my God, I went to college. Hmm. And are you ready for the alt?
那会紧接着放在这里吗？是的。好的。准备好了吗？是的。哦，粉丝讨论版当时肯定会炸锅的。所以这里会有一个偷拍镜头，拍到凯西在用手机和她的一个朋友通话。真的吗？嗯哼。你猜她说了什么？什么？只要帕姆对那些小毛孩感到厌烦，我立刻就失业了。嘿，也许我应该当她的保姆？我朋友就是保姆。我们可以在公园里一起闲逛。哦，天哪，我可是上过大学的。嗯。准备好听替代版本了吗？
What's the alt? Must shoot alt. There's footage of this somewhere. Kathy would have said on the phone. I hadn't seen it before, but Jim kind of has that sexy dad thing going on if, like, you're into sexy dads. I have to say something. What? I feel like they did not know what to do with this character of Kathy.
什么是替代版本？必拍替代版本。某个地方有这段素材。凯西会在电话里说。我以前没看过这个，但吉姆身上那种性感老爸的特质，如果你喜欢性感老爸这一挂的话。我得说点什么。什么？我觉得他们根本不知道该怎么处理凯西这个角色。
No, they didn't. Because for the trivia episode, they had written a whole thing where Pam invited Kathy over to meet the new baby to her house. Yes. And now you have this thing going on. I feel like there's this really big gap in the story of Kathy, this character. And I'm really interested to get into it with Lindsay because that episode of Pam's replacement is great. It's a great idea. She kills it. It's so fun. And then, Basically, she's just in the background. Yeah. Until Tallahassee when she throws herself at Jim. It's very, it makes her seem cray cray. But the truth is, is that there were all these little things.
不，他们不知道。因为在问答那一集里，他们写了一整段剧情，讲帕姆邀请凯西去她家看新出生的宝宝。是的。而现在你又遇到了这种情节。我觉得凯西这个角色的故事线存在一个非常大的断层。我真的很想和林赛一起深入探讨这一点，因为帕姆的替身那一集太棒了。这是一个绝妙的主意。她演得太棒了。非常有趣。然后，基本上，她就只能在背景里打酱油了。是的。直到去塔拉哈西那集她主动投怀送抱。这让人觉得她有点疯疯癫癫的。但事实是，有这么多细碎的小情节。
Like, what is she? Is she friends with Jim and Pam? Is she hot for Jim? Like, they were throwing a lot at this character. And I feel like never really found her purpose. Right. Yeah, I'm excited to talk to Lindsay about it, too, because her being a foil to Pam, I get, you know, I get that idea.
比如，她算什么？她是吉姆和帕姆的朋友吗？她对吉姆有非分之想吗？他们在这个角色身上倾注了太多东西。我觉得她从来没有真正找到自己的定位。对。是的，我也很高兴和林赛谈论这个，因为她作为帕姆的衬托，我懂，我理解那个构思。
But then they never set her up to do that correctly as a character. Yeah, like they wrote things for her, but they were never aired. So the Tallahassee thing really comes out of the blue. Yeah. But what people should know is that it was there, it was being written, but it wasn't making it into the episodes. Yeah. Well, this episode ends with Dwight bursting into the office, smoking a cigar. and he has a talking head.
但他们从来没有把她塑造好，没能让她作为一个角色正确地发挥这种作用。是的，就像他们为她写了剧情，但从未播出过。所以塔拉哈西的情节让人觉得有点莫名其妙。对。但大家应该知道的是，这些内容是存在的，剧本也写了，只是没有剪进正片里。好吧，这一集的结尾是德怀特抽着雪茄冲进办公室。他有一段访谈镜头。
He forgives Jim. He does. You know why? He was doing it for his kids. And us dads, you know? He says, us dads. Yeah. He's a dad.
他原谅了吉姆。他确实原谅了。你知道为什么吗？他是为了自己的孩子才这么做的。而我们这些当爸爸的，你知道吗？他说，我们这些当爸爸的。是的。他是个爸爸。
He's a dad. Or so he thinks. Or is he. No spoilers. What if this is someone's first time watching the show? No spoilers. All right. I won't say anything, but we'll get there.
他是个爸爸。或者他自己是这么认为的。或者他是吗。没有剧透。万一这是某人第一次看这部剧呢？没有剧透。好吧。我什么都不说，但我们会聊到那里的。
Yeah, we will. Well, that was jury duty. I loved watching this episode. I'm so excited, Pam's back. I want to give a big thank you to Steve Burgess and Erin Scher. We both reached out. Yes, and Hallstead for answering my question about his name. And to all of you for writing in with your great catches and questions. You guys have a great week. We'll see you next week. See you then. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our in-studio engineer is Sam Kiefer. Our editing and mixing engineer is Jordan Duffy. And our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbico. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
是的，我们会聊到的。好了，这就是陪审团义务那一集。我很喜欢看这一集。我太兴奋了，帕姆回来了。我要对史蒂夫·伯吉斯和艾琳·谢尔表示巨大的感谢。我们两个都联系了。是的，还有霍尔斯特德回答了我关于他名字的问题。也感谢所有写信分享精彩发现和提问的你们。祝大家过个愉快的一周。我们下周见。回头见。感谢收听“办公室辣妈”。“办公室辣妈”由Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西联合制作。我们的资深制作人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的录音室工程师是萨姆·基弗。我们的剪辑和混音工程师是乔丹·达菲。我们的助理制作人是艾恩斯利·布比科。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。本集还没有评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可留下评论。